Ja, Herr Moderator.
Was ist denn das für ein Geräusch im Hintergrund?
Ähm, Geräusch?
Konkretes Geräusch. Schönen guten Abend, Chaosradio.
Schönen guten Abend.
Gäste im Studio, wie immer, beziehungsweise ausführende Dingens im Studio.
Ausführende Dingens im Studio, diesmal.
Die Stimme, die kennen wir. Andi Müller mag gut. Pluto, guten Abend. Und Duby, Duby aus, äh, was, wo kommst du her? Werden wir schplattern.
Wunderbaren Rheinland.
Ja, wir sind hier in Chaosradio 47. Internet-Strukturen, gehackte Computerverantwortung, Verbindlichkeit, Anonymität, digitale Signaturen. Also wir haben das ursprüngliche Thema der Sendung ein bisschen erweitert, weil wir uns über digitale Signaturen überlegt haben, weil wir nicht wirklich zwei Stunden reden und außerdem interessiert das auch keinen. Aber wir haben gute Gründe, über das, was wir im Netz gerade nicht haben, nämlich über Verbindlichkeit, mal ein bisschen zu reden, aufgrund aktueller Ereignisse.
Das klang ja jetzt auch vergleichsweise hochtrabend, ne?
Worum geht's? Genau, du solltest ja auch danach die Musik...
Achso, ich soll die Musik wieder hochtraben lassen. Das ist die Dramatik. Es tut mir sehr leid, aber... Peter, der Techniker, macht hier Sachen, die mich sehr verwirren. Der spielt nämlich hier an Nippeln rum.
Apropos an Nippeln. Soll ich jetzt hier mal auf die Nippel drücken, oder?
Nippel?
So, ich fang dann auch mal mit der Musik an und dann haben wir noch eine Untermalung.
Eine Untermalung, ja dann. Lass mal rein.
Da musst du mal hoch drehen.
Ich drehe auch hoch, also ich ziehe, man sagt ziehen.
Man sagt ziehen, cool. Dann machen wir das mal auf Fullscreen. Ah, das könnt ihr jetzt nicht sehen.
Ach, Fullscreen hat was mit Audio zu tun. Ich wusste, dass ich irgendwas falsch mache.
Ja, wir machen jetzt mal ein Experiment. Wir hören uns jetzt einfach gleichzeitig in drei Stunden mp3 an. Und außerdem habe ich hier gerade noch Blätraner auf DVD. Und wir haben uns überlegt, das ist so schön, melodramatisch. Schöner geht es gar nicht mehr.
Also das Wort melodramatisch hätte ich mir bei einem akustischen Overkill irgendwie nicht vorgestellt.
Aus dem Post Blätraner ja eigentlich auch ganz gut zum eigentlichen ursprünglichen Thema im Sinne von Identitäten und... Ah, dann bekehren sie mal und holen sie sich das Mikro ein bisschen näher ran. Wo war jetzt der Zusammenhang zwischen Blätraner und digitalen Signaturen? Na im Prinzip zwischen Identitäten, weil Blätraner geht mehr oder weniger darum, dass Leute sich als Mensch verkleiden, die eigentlich keine sind, mehr oder weniger. Und wie man erkennt, ob jemand der ist, der eher vorgibt zu sein, ist ein ziemlich starker Bestandteil. Sprich, die Technik, die dahinter steht, ist recht interessant. Von daher passt das auch ganz gut. Die Attacken, die jetzt kommen, hatten ja auch viel mit sich versteckend zu tun. Dann sollen wir uns das so vorstellen, wie diese erste Szene hier, so Identitätsgriffung. Schönen guten Tag. Was denken Sie am allerschönsten über Ihre Mutter und dann halt pengen?
Ja, kommt man natürlich zur Frage, ob man denn überhaupt sein muss, was man vorgibt zu sein. Also du gehst davon aus, dass man irgendwie Identität haben muss und die darlegen und immer gleich ist.
Also um das nochmal dem Radiohörer vielleicht zu versuchen, zu übersetzen. Wir haben hier keine Identitätskrise, sondern worüber wir reden wollen ist, wie ist eigentlich der Zusammenhang zwischen Anonymität, Unverbindlichkeit, Verbindlichkeit im Netz und kann man mit dem Netz, so wie es jetzt eigentlich ist, zum Beispiel so eine Weltwirtschaft fahren, was Sie ja gerade versuchen. Also da gibt es ja so lauter Karattenträger, die glauben alle an den sogenannten neuen Markt. Und dieser basiert komischerweise auf dem Funktionieren des Netzes, des Internetzes, unseres Internetzes, mit dem wir lauter schöne Dinge tun, aber nicht unbedingt nur Geld drucken. Ja, also im Prinzip versucht da der E-Commerce aus der Blümchenwiese den Single Point of Failure für die gesamte informationstechnologische Gesellschaft zu machen.
Single Point of Failure?
Also im Prinzip, wenn du irgendwie ein System hast, in dem es einen einzigen Punkt gibt, den du ausmachst, dann ist das ganze System aus, dann hast du einen Single Point of Failure.
Ja, und der E-Commerce macht auch das Internet plötzlich so wichtig. Ich meine, jeder von uns kann mal ganz gut, sagen wir, zwei, drei Stunden ohne Internet leben. Da passiert nichts, das ist zwar ärgerlich, aber das geht. Aber irgendwie eine E-Commerce-Firma, die wird da ganz viel kribbeliger von. Und meint gleich, ihre Aktien irgendwie in den Boden rammen zu müssen.
Ja, auch eine der Theorien war, woran das gelegen haben könnte mit den Angriffen auf die diverse Zeit. Zum Sinne von, wenn ich weiß, dass morgen ein Angriff auch zum Beispiel eine Zeit läuft und die dann für 24 Stunden weg ist, dann werde ich halt heute Aktien kaufen. Äh, nein, morgen Aktien kaufen, die wir morgen wieder verkaufen. Im Sinne von Manipulationen und... Also hört gut zu, ihr werdet dann erfahren, wie ihr stinkend reich werdet. Ja, der Trip zum Geldverdienen. Tino und Daytime Broker. Ich glaube, wir müssen uns erst mal Musik hören und machen uns ein Konzept, oder?
Genau, und ihr verraten mir oft eher die wirklichen Geheimnisse. Alles, was ich hab.
Auf Ja und es scheint wirklich sehr, sehr gut abzugehen.
Wir haben schon den ersten Anrufer, ne? Das ist der Daniel, Name Daniel.
Na?
Was ist dein Punkt?
Ja, also ich würde sagen im Internet kann man total leicht die Identität verfälschen, denn also ich kann mich meinetwegen auch im Chat reifen oder so. Also es kriegt auch keiner mit.
Und, findest du das okay? Macht's Spaß?
Ich find das macht Spaß. Wir machen das auch mit denen aus meiner Klasse. Ja, verarschen wir eben, dass ein Schüler eben immer mailt und haben eine Mailadresse angedeckt und so. Frisch ist das geil.
Und was denken eure Lehrer darüber? Kriegen die schon graue Haare oder haben sie die ohnehin?
Naja, die Lehrer, die bemerken das ja nicht. Also die wissen, dass wir sowieso eine Schule tun und dass wir damit eigentlich eh schlechte Tensionen kriegen, ob wir im Internet sind oder nicht.
Okay, dann machen wir das mal versuchen zu verbessern. Wärst du dann selber gerne so, wie du im Internet tun kannst, dass du wirst oder so durch eine falsche Identität, die du überhältst?
Nee, ich bin lieber so, wie ich bin, weil da kann man noch welche kennenlernen.
Daniel, danke für dein Beitrag. Ich hab nie einen Turtel gesehen. Es ist ein Test, der sich um eine emotionale Antwort auswirft.
Beschreib in einzelnen Worten nur die guten Dinge, die in deinem Gehirn kommen.
Tja, so viel zum Thema Identitätskrisen und emotionale Reaktionen. Aber mal im Ernst, was da gerade passiert ist, sozusagen dieser verteilte Angriff distribuiert den NLF Service. Da stellen wir uns ja auch noch ein bisschen die Frage, war das irgendwie eine emotionale Reaktion? Also hat da irgendein 14-jähriger schlechte Laune gehabt und sich überlegt, jetzt fahren wir einfach mal Yahoo! runter und jetzt fahren wir einfach mal CNN! runter und jetzt zeigen wir es denen mal. Also das Machtgefühl, das du hast, wenn du irgendwie da alleine in einem Rechner sitzt und weißt, dass da draußen die Zeits, die aus Millionen gebaut sind, plötzlich irgendwie gerade nicht responsive sind und dass irgendwie Leute da draußen darauf nicht zugreifen können. Und du alleine sitzt da und hast die Macht, es an- und auszumachen. Du meinst, das ist so wie das Gefühl bei Fight Club, wo sie da in einem Hofhaus stehen und irgendwie das Panorama bricht zusammen und da sagt er einfach, du hast mich einfach in einem komischen Moment meines Lebens kennengelernt.
Na ja, aber eigentlich hat man das so einmal oder zweimal, das ist dann cool, aber nicht irgendwie wochenlang.
Also die Frage ist, haben wir so viele Früh- oder Spätpupertiere, die darauf abgefahren, oder haben wir, ich sehe hier heftiges Nicken mit uns.
Ich war es nicht, ich war das nicht.
Ja, also wir waren es nicht. Das sollten wir euch Leute jetzt nochmal ganz klar erklären. Der Chaos Computer Club hat damit also zu Abwechslung mal nichts zu tun, wir dementieren, also alles.
Sind vorhin denn irgendwie bei euch eingeritten, die Wolker oder so?
Nee, also es ist halt so, dass es gab halt, als die ersten Meldungen kamen, so am Dienstag, vor zwei Wochen jetzt schon, und da bin ich halt mal so durch die Mailinglisten durchgegangen und hab geguckt, was ist da so gerade los in Amerika, weil ich ja jetzt auch nicht jeden Tag alles lese. Und da kam halt relativ zeitnah so Meldung, ja das ist gerade ein Programm gegen Computer, also Cyber Terrorist hat finden gerade an das sogenannte NIPC, das National Infrastructure Protection Committee, das sollte zwei Milliarden Dollar für Cyber Terrorismus kriegen und es hat eine Senatsanhörung gegeben, wo also etliche Senatoren gefragt haben, was denn das überhaupt sein soll, Cyber Terrorismus, weil die amerikanische Öffentlichkeit da auch unterschiedlich informiert ist, und dann halt schwupp zwei Tage später irgendwie, gibt's auf einmal Cyber Terrorismus und keiner kann mir nicht mehr sagen, dass er es nicht weiß irgendwie. Also da gab es halt schon eine zeitliche Nähe und ich hab dann halt ein bisschen zu laut vielleicht die Fahnen auf dem Weben Nütztes gestellt, wo dann einige gleich draus gemacht haben, ja der Chaos Computer Club sagt, die Amerikaner waren es, das haben wir nicht gesagt. Ich hab mir gedacht, der Hacker-Szene nützt das nicht. Und irgendwelchen 14-Jährigen, ich meine, okay, das Machtgefühl ist vielleicht nett, klar, aber dann würden sie normalerweise auch so weit gehen zu sagen, ich war es. Normalerweise würde dann einer sagen, ich zapf Dingbaz oder wie auch immer, ich war es, ich hab das Internet runtergefahren und die Welt gerettet. Aber da gab es irgendwie wenig Information. Na ja, sich hinterher dann noch verantwortlich fürzustellen und noch noch den Medienrummel abzukriegen. Den Medienrummel hat hier jemand anders abgekriegt, nämlich der, der eventuell das Programm geschrieben hat. Eines der Programme. Eines der Programme hat die eventuell dabei benutzt worden.
Mixed-Aus, oder?
Vielleicht sollten wir das doch nochmal erklären, wie das funktioniert. In dem hast du eben gesagt, dass es eine nette freudische Fehlleistung drin ist. In dem Sinne von, die zwei Milliarden sind nicht für Cyber-Terrorismus, sondern gegen Cyber-Terrorismus. Wer fehlt das so unterscheiden? Also, dass die Amis sich die Informationen, die sie da kriegen, mit diesem Programm gegen eventuell dann auch mal nutzen, um damit kleine Inselstaaten platz zu machen, wie das gerade die Chinesen und die Taiwanesenschöne vormachen, ist da natürlich auch noch ein Aspekt irgendwo.
Aber lass uns erst mal erklären, was ein Hacker aus dem Münsterland mit einer russischen Hackergruppe zu tun hat und einem Programm, das Stacheldraht heißt.
Also fangen wir mal von vorne an. Es gibt im Internet eine Angriffsform, die heißt die Nylor Service. Das sind Angriffe auf die Verfügbarkeit, zum Beispiel durch Überlastung von Computern mit regulären Anfragen. Und das ist auch das, was hier geschehen ist. Dagegen kann man sich nicht schützen. Das ist so, als würde ich hier zu Radio Fritz irgendwie hunderte von Pizza-Service oder ein paar Firmen, die vielleicht Zement anliefern, irgendwie anrufen und da irgendwie Kram bestellen und dann würden die hier anfangen euch vom allerfeinsten den Eingang zu zu betonieren. So, ihr habt nun mal einen Eingang und ihr könnt das Gebäude nicht in Luft auflösen und ihr könnt eventuell den Leuten sagen, irgendwie will ich nicht, aber in dem Moment, wo die angefangen haben, da die Kanüle aufzumachen, ist halt vorbei.
Es sei denn, ich sage dem Pferd nach vorne, er möge diesen LKW nicht mehr durchlassen, aber dann kommen auch die Leute, die hier arbeiten wollen, nicht durch.
So ist das, röderweise im Internet ist das so. Da kannst du dem Pferdner leider nicht so richtig differenzierte Hinweise geben. Na, das geht schon. Also der Pferdner ist im Prinzip dann dein Borderrouter, den du halt bei deinem Netz hast von deiner Site. Ja, wenn du es dann selbst hast und nicht dein Internetprovider. Oder dein Provider, den musst du halt anrufen, was hier jetzt mittlerweile dann wohl auch können, was berichtet wurde, dass man da jetzt dann auch Telefonlisten hat, wen man anrufen muss in solchen Fällen. Das Problem ist, stellt euch vor, das ganze Internet ist aus Paketen basiert, sprich Pakete werden hin und her geschickt und irgendwie kommt jemand auf die Idee, euch zehn große Post-LKWs mit Paketen zu schicken und die kippt ihr euch vor die Tür, egal ob ihr wollt oder nicht. Und damit müsst ihr dann erstmal fertig werden.
Ja, und das große Problem ist halt, im Internet ist es so weltweit verbreitet und verzweicht, so könnte man vielleicht jemanden an die nächste Kreuzung stellen, der die LKWs umleitet oder auch an die Übernext oder an die Autobahnabfahrt. Aber bis man bei so einem Angriff alle Internetprovider, über deren Rechner das gelaufen ist, gefunden hat, ist dann auch Weihnachten.
Gut, aber um nochmal ganz kurz in der Erklärung vielleicht weiterzumachen, also es gibt Denial of Service und es gibt noch was gemeineres und das, was hier geschehen ist, das ist Distributed Denial of Service. Und das weist sozusagen auf ein ganz neues Problem im Internet, um nicht zu sagen auf ein Problem, das wir längst kennen und auch wissen, aber was jetzt irgendwie tatsächlich mal Auswirkungen hat. Computer sind oftmals unsicher, okay, wenn jemand einen Atomkraftwerk betreibt, sagt man halt normalerweise, okay, beim Atomkraftwerk gibt es so gesetzliche Bestimmungen und dies und das, da hat der bestimmte Sachen einzuhalten, sonst darf er das Ding nicht betreiben, weil das könnte uns um die Ohren fliegen. Chemiewerk genau dasselbe, andere Geschäftsbereiche auch. Wenn jemand einen unsicheren Computer am Internet hat, hat man bisher gesagt, scheißegal, sein Problem. Wenn du hast unsicher Computer, Elan, hast du Problem. Wenn du hast unsicher Auto, ist Problem.
Wobei wir sagen müssen, das gilt jetzt für Leute, die einen Server da betreiben, also jetzt nicht den User zu Hause, oder?
Ja, wobei man könnte auch, das ist der nächste Schritt da. Reden wir dann mal über die nächsten Angriffsformen. Angriffsformen entwickeln können wir ja dann natürlich immer machen. Langer Rede, kurzer Sinn. Also hier wurden unsichere Computer ausgenutzt als Angriffswerkzeug, und zwar als automatisiertes. Das heißt, man hat ein paar Computer gehackt, da ein Angriffswerkzeug verteilt und denen dann gesagt, so und jetzt macht ihr CNN-Cut. Und CNN hat zwar dann irgendwann rausgefunden, und ja hu, wer es war, aber das waren dann eben nur die Computer, die den Angriffen haben und nicht der Mensch.
Aber Andi, dass du gemeint hast, da sagt man immer, dass es egal, wenn dein Computer unsicher ist, das stimmt so nicht bei dem E-Mail-Spam. Hatte man das eigentlich, hat man das schon seit Jahren. Wenn du einen Rechner so konfiguriert hast, dass andere Leute darüber unerwünschte Mails weiterleiten, dann kriegst du unheimlich den Arsch voll.
Kriegst du keinen Spam?
Ich krieg schon Spam, aber ich hatte mal einen Rechner, der als Spam-Value benutzt wurde, und dann hast du etwa 500 Mails von Mail-Admins, die sagen, du sollst augenblicklich deinen Rechner sicher machen, sonst würden sie irgendwie selber persönlich mit der Drahtschere vorbei.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber das Konzept scheint ja nicht zu greifen. Also wenn ich dir hier mal kurz am Bildschirm zeigen darf, ich kriege hier mittlerweile ungefähr, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist es arabischer Spam, vielleicht ist es chinesischer, also ich kann es nicht mal mehr beim besten Willen entziffern.
So.
Also es gibt da schon Methoden, die irgendwo mehr Nachhaltigkeit und irgendwo mehr Verantwortung für den eigenen Rechner im Internet irgendwie entforcen wollen. Das ist z.B.
RBL oder auch, wie heissen die nochmal, Orbs.
Ja, für Mail.
Für Mail, also wo du halt, als wenn du ein offener Relay-Host bist, d.h. wenn du ein Host bist, über den andere Leute schnell mal irgendwie eine Million Mails an Spam-Empfänger schicken können, dann wirst du in einer dieser beiden Datenbanken eingetragen. Und wenn du ein guter Admin bist, dann schaust du halt, wenn dir jemand eine Mail schicken möchte, erst mal wieder Datenbanken. Aber ist das jetzt gerade ein konstruktiver Ansatz oder kommen wir gerade vom Thema ab?
Wir sind auf jeden Fall im Thema. Die Frage ist, ob das ein guter Ansatz ist. Aber im Prinzip ist ja, wenn du jede Menge E-Mail kommst, das auch eine Denial-of-Service-Attacke. Und in diesem Bereich gibt es solche Sachen. Was anderes ist Smurf. Das ist ja eine Attacke, die vor einigen Jahren gelaufen ist. Und da hat man ein Datenpaket losgeschickt, was gleich dann von einigen hundert Rechnern beantwortet wurde und auf einen Rechner gebündelt wurde und den platt gemacht hat. Und da gab es automatische Scans auf Netze, die Smurf erlaubten und die sind einfach an den Core-Hutern ausgeblendet worden. Also da hat man im Prinzip schon gesagt, eure Rechner sind unsicher, dann würden wir nicht mehr mit euch reden. Das hat mal geklappt.
Ja, das hat mal geklappt. Was jetzt halt passiert ist, aber erstmal ist, dass diejenigen, die diese Angriffswerkzeuge geschrieben haben und darunter ist halt unter anderem ein, wie soll ich sagen, noch Entwicklungsfähiger, 20-jähriger, Jugendlicher aus irgendwo Deutschland, der halt geschickterweise auch noch dpa geschrieben hat, ja ja, ich hab das Angriffswerkzeug irgendwie entwickelt und die haben daraus gemacht, Schuldeingeständnis und daraus wurde dann gleich ein Haftbefehl und ah, so komische Dinge sind passiert. Also die Sache hatte dann schon eine Dynamik, weil da irgendwie echt Leute sich geärgert haben. Und naja, wir wollen jetzt, glaube ich, nochmal zu den Abwehrmethoden kommen. Ja, die Abwehrmethoden, also das eben mit den E-Mails, das ist halt schon irgendwo ein Ansatz im Sinne von, genauso wie zum Beispiel in den App Store. Ja, aber dann müssen wir ja ungefähr 80% der Computer im Internet müssen wir dann als Nicht-Malide-Host austragen. Und ich glaube, da würden die echt irgendwie einen Kackreiz kriegen. Also die würden schlechte Laune kriegen, so. Das wäre aber eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Also wenn man sich so manchen Rechner da draußen anguckt, also es gibt mittlerweile ein Plugin für Browser, das tatsächlich so einen Trick macht. Es scannt den Host, mit dem gerade verbunden wird, nach bekannten Sicherheitslücken und hält dem User das dann mit. Im Sinne von, du willst hier gerade mit diesem Host etwas machen, aber sei vorsichtig, weil dieser Host ist angreifbar über POP3 und IMAP2 oder so. Du meinst du als automatisiertes Hinweistool? Für den User ganz persönlich, ob der Rechner, mit dem er da arbeiten möchte, irgendwie so wenigstens die Minimalvorschriften einhält.
Aber entschuldige, der User, der sich drin befindet, der versteht auch gar nicht, was das heißt, was da zurückkommt.
Na, wenn ihr das Tool einfach sagt, rote Lampe, grüne Lampe, dann ist das schon irgendwo relativ verständlich. Aber das klappt halt nicht mit so Sachen, wo Server in großen Mengen aufgemacht werden, um da Angriffstools zu installieren. Wenn es so laufen würde wie bei diesen Mails, bräuchte man halt sozusagen eine Cyberforce Police, die durchscannet, wer ist hier automatisiert, hackbar mit allem, was gerade beim Zert über die diversen Bugtracklisten gelaufen ist. Und dann halt den Leuten entweder sagt so, wir machen jetzt das Internet aus oder... Also müsste das die Polizei machen oder wie? Ich meine, die geht ja auch nicht rum und sagt, also schonmal ihre Wohnungstür steht offen oder ihr Fenster ist nur angelehnt und man könnte es jetzt aufwecken. Also gestern Abend stand bei mir jemand im Büro und hat mich darauf hingewiesen, dass abends meine Büro... am Abend vorher meine Bürotour irgendwie nicht abgeschlossen war. Da geht man zum Anzug. Der ist zwar privat bezahlt, aber...
Bei uns in Köln ist sogar öfters die Polizei da und fragt, warum denn die Haustür offen steht.
Sehr freundliche, junge Männer mit Taschenlampen und dann sagt man abends, ne, wir sind noch hier und dann sagen die so, ne...
Ich dachte, das kommt aus Brühl in der Polizeischule. Die üben.
Das kann schon sein.
Na gut, und wir üben jetzt... Darf ich auch noch mal strukturieren?
Ja, das ist keine schlechte Idee. Wir hören dann...
Dann haben wir noch dieses Fritz-Dings da, ne?
Die Wahrheit. 22.30, halb elf.
Demonstrationen, rund 2000 Menschen haben am Abend in Brandenburg-Hafel gegen die geplanten Kürzungen bei den Kitas protestiert. Vertreter der Demonstranten übergaben Listen mit gesammelten Unterschriften. Zu den Protesten hatte die Gewerkschaft ÖTV aufgerufen. Sie sieht durch die Einsparung den gesetzlichen Betreuungsanspruch in Kindertagesstätten und Arbeitsplätze bedroht. Fortschritt, die Einrichtung von sogenannten Fixerstuben, wird in Deutschland legalisiert. Der Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundesrat und Bundestag einigte sich am Abend auf einen leicht geänderten Gesetzentwurf. Morgen soll das Gesetz dem Bundestag passieren. Vorhaben Bundeskanzler Schröder will EDV-Experten aus dem Ausland nach Deutschland holen. Bei der Eröffnung der Computermesse Cebit am Abend in Hannover sagte Schröder, man werde den Fachkräften eine Aufenthaltserlaubnis nach dem Vorbild der US Green Card geben. Gleichzeitig forderte der Kanzler die Wirtschaft auf, arbeitslose deutsche Ingenieure für die Computerbranche umzuschulen. Ermittlungen der beabsichtigte Amoklauf der Schülerinnen in Münchenberg war von ihr in allen Einzelheiten geplant. Laut Staatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt Oder wollte die 16-Jährige mit Handgranaten und halbautomatischen Waffen Schüler und Lehrer ihres Gymnasiums töten. Ihr droht nun eine Anklage wegen geplanten Mordes. Lawinenopfer fünf Menschen sind heute in den französischen Alpen ums Leben gekommen. Eine Person wurde schwer verletzt. Zum Zeitpunkt des Lawinenabgangs befand sich die Skifahrergruppe außerhalb der markierten Pisten. Fußball. Die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat ihr Testspiel für die EM in den Niederlanden mit 1 zu 2 verloren. Wetter. Heute Nacht gering bewirkt bei 0 bis minus 4 Grad, noch mal kalt und am Tag dann bewirkt und regnerisch, noch mal regnerisch um 7 Grad. Verkehr. Zurzeit keine aktuellen Meldungen.
Herzlichen Dank ein Fritz Kurzinfo mit Gerald Kötterheinrich. Das Ganze um 22 und 32 Minuten.
Fritz präsentiert. Freitag, 3. März in der Vögener Straße 28 in Werder bei Potsdam.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Immer noch Chaos Radio.
Ach so, ja Chaosradio 47. Wir haben gerade beschlossen, während hier der Nachrichtensprecher kurz geredet hat, wir werden jetzt das Thema der Sendung umschmeißen. Also wenn 16-Jährige jetzt schon Maschinengewehre horten und ihre Mitschüler bedrohen, dann bedrohen sie bestimmt auch das Internet über. Lass uns über die Jugend reden. Du meinst, da so Handgranaten in Server-Räumen? Ja, also es kamen ja auch schon die Eingabe, vielleicht waren es die Kampftiffer, so die 14- bis, wie alt sind die so? 14- bis 17-Jährigen, also ob es die nicht eventuell waren, dann hätten wir noch zur Auswahl die 2000 Mütter gegen die Kitterschließung, ob es die nicht eventuell waren.
Und den Kanzler an der Station.
Ich finde, wir nehmen jetzt mal Anrufe dazu rein. Wir haben jetzt einfach noch mal bis 11 Uhr Zeit, kurz darüber zu reden, ganz entspannt, bevor wir dann zum Thema der Sendung kommen, nämlich wie man Verbindlichkeit im Netz tatsächlich steigert. Also wer war es? Wir wollen es jetzt einfach mal wissen.
Ja genau, wer war es hier?
Wer war es? Wer hat die Rechner runtergefahren? Was glaubt ihr? Habt ihr eine Lieblingstheorie oder sollten wir lieber mal was anderes reden?
Und sagen könnt ihr das hier.
Die Fritz Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Podstar 7097 110.
Die Musik ist...
Nee, die läuft. Achso, Entschuldigung. Ich hab nur zwischendurch immer mal wieder so ein bisschen, wenn wir diese schönen Vangelis komponierten...
Ist das jetzt Blade Runner oder ist das jetzt...
Das ist Blade Runner, ja.
Machen wir es eigentlich strafbar gerade?
Du schon, ja. Nee, wir zahlen ja doch GEMA, oder?
Ah ja genau, wir zahlen ja GEMA.
Hallo. Otis?
Ja, hier bin ich.
Und du wolltest uns erzählen, wie du weißt, wer das ist, oder wer das war, oder wer das wieder sein wird.
Die Frage war, wer mag denn wohl diese Denial-of-Service-Attacken gemacht haben?
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Schade.
Das denn, wer war's?
Naja, ich würde mal sagen, irgendwelche, meine Meinung nach Idioten.
Das ist recht unspezifisch, Idioten gibt's ja viele.
Also meinst du Idioten, die Krawatten tragen, Idioten, die das falsche Kraut rauchen, oder Idioten, die einfach nur schlechte Laune haben oder Fußballspiele verloren haben, weißt du welche?
Naja, die wahrscheinlich haben irgendwelche Depressionen oder so.
Thomas, wer war's?
Wer war's?
Ich würd eher sagen, es waren irgendwelche bescheuerten Cracker da, oder wie sie jetzt heißen, Crasher. Diese neue Bezeichnung da, es gibt da den Unterschied zwischen Hackern und Crackern da irgendwie. Die Hacker, die locken sich in ein System ein und holen ihre Information raus, zerstören das System, oder nicht auch die Cracker, locken sich halt in ein System, einen zerstören, oder irgendwie behindern Services oder sowas. Ich würde eher sagen, es waren solche, irgendwelche Kaputten da, die halt nicht wissen, was mit ihrer Fähigkeit anfangen können oder können oder so.
Und warum sollen sie es gemacht haben deiner Meinung nach?
Ich kenne die Motive nicht, ich bin kein Cracker, aber ich würde mal so sagen, reine Lust am Spass oder so.
Also meinst du die Leute, die auch schon irgendwie auf dem Spielplatz damals den anderen Leuten immer die Bagger kaputt gemacht haben?
Ha, weitergeholtes Beispiel, aber man könnte es fast zu bezeichnen.
Okay, die bösen Cracker waren es. Danke Thomas. Und wir haben die erste drei Buchstaben-Organisationen. Schönen guten Abend, Frank.
Ah ja, hallo. Also ich bin der Meinke, das war der NSE. Ja, weil das hängt da alles ein bisschen zusammen. Ich meine, das war ja ein Kinderstreich, die ganze Sache. Also wenn man sich das so ein bisschen betrachtet, gleich danach hat der Präsident da 2 Milliarden oder wie viel Geld er da freigeben zur Bekämpfung von Computer-Hackern. Und wenn unser Innenminister da auch noch in dasselbe Horn stößt, dann könnte man doch denken, dass das eventuell ein figiertes Ding, der dieses Geheimdienstes war, um wieder ein neues Feindbild aufzubauen und praktisch den Geheimdienst damit gehend Geld an Zuverfügung zu stellen, um die Leute noch mehr zu bespitzeln und so.
Naja, die Budget-Rechtfertigung.
Also so denkt man, denn das ist ja eine Sache, wenn man sich das mal so betrachtet, da ist ja in dem Sinne, außer, dass die Server runtergefahren sind, nicht so ein gravierender Schaden entstanden. Wenn, so wie die jetzt das Uffbauschen, wenn die jetzt Daten manipuliert hätten oder so was, dann wird vielleicht eine andere Sache, aber ich sage mal so, die haben da praktisch was gemacht, was nicht allzu großen Schaden entstehen lässt, aber praktisch, indem sie jetzt in den Medien jetzt so sind, da in der Bevölkerung so ein Unsicherheitsgefühl verbreiten, dass die jetzt sagen, der Ereignis, der muss da was machen gegen die bösen Hacker und so und so.
Das verblüfft mich eben auch, also gemessen an der Möglichkeit, die man gehabt hätte, Schaden anzurichten, ist der Schaden vergleichsweise gering gewesen.
Also einen Monat vorher lief so als kleine Anekdote am Rande, oder so zwei Monate vorher hat ein russischer Hacker in dem Fall, oder Cracker oder whatever, einen Rechner in uns aufgemacht und 300.000 irgendwie Kundendaten inklusive gültigen Kreditkartennummern rausgemacht und es gab irgendwie eine kleine Meldung in so ein paar Computernachrichtentikern, hat ansonsten keinen weiter interessiert.
Also für mich stinkt das ganz danach, dass da irgendwie ein Heimdienst da seine Finger im Spiel hatte, praktisch oben, ja, da das Gelder locker gemacht werden und man sieht das ja auch, unsere Regierung reagiert ja auch darauf, unser Schili, der will ja da auch irgendwie eine Rechte, der Wetter einschränken und so.
Ja, Kompetenzsimulationen allenorts auf jeden Fall. Ja, da kann man auch gleich zur Entlastung von Schili sagen, er hat wenigstens erst hinterher reagiert, also im Sinne von er hat nicht vorher dran gedacht, er hat erst irgendwie so eine Woche später dran gedacht, also er ist schon mal irgendwie aus der Liste der möglichen raus. Klinik hat jetzt schon zwei Monate vorher das Geld freigegeben. Naja, also wir notieren das jetzt erstmal und diskutieren dann hinterher, weil ich danke für deinen Anruf, würde ich sagen.
Ja, vielen Dank Frank, die NSA war es also. Ja, wer war es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Wer hat die den All-of-Service-Attacken gefahren?
Wir könnten natürlich theoretisch zwischendurch auch nochmal kurz zur technischen Erörterung kommen, also warum war das Ganze möglich so? Weil Computer unsicher sind, haben wir jetzt vorhin ein bisschen generalmäßig gesagt, warum sind Computer unsicher, könnten wir jetzt mal ganz kurz. Also die Einbrüche, auf denen die Angriffswerkzeuge installiert wurden, basierten ja auf bekannten Fehlern. Das ist sozusagen erschreckend, also es ist so, als würden die Leute in ein Auto fahren, von dem alle wissen, dass ab und zu die Reifen versagen. Und der Hersteller hat es eigentlich auch schon zur Kenntnis genommen.
Aber du sprichst vom Audi TT, ja?
Naja, Andy, das ist schon was anderes. Also es wissen nicht alle, dass wir da sind, sondern nur die Techniker wissen das. Und das sind wenige Leute. Es ist wie ein Auto, wo die Werkstatt weiß, dass es kaputt ist und es wird nicht zurückgerufen. Also die meisten Benutzer wissen ja nicht, dass ihr Server irgendwie eine IMAP-Exportability hat.
Ja, aber ich meine, die Firma Sun kann ja auch schlecht ihren Kunden sagen, jetzt kommt mit euren Servern mal vorbeigefahren irgendwie. Aber sie hätten ein bisschen früher vielleicht schon mal reagieren können. Das ist sozusagen der Elchtest für das Internet irgendwie oder?
Gibt es denn auch ein ESP, also was den Umfall verhindert für das Internet?
Oder gar ein TÜV.
Na, es ist irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig. Ich meine, der TÜV sieht da jetzt gerade seine Chance. Da waren Leute, die sich auf seine Veranstaltungen veranstalten und da wollte er wirklich, ja, jetzt müsste man doch in diesem Best-Site BSI natürlich auch, also jeder zieht da durch sein Nutzen auf. Die Aktienkurse von Firmen, die eben Computer-Sicherheitsprodukte verkaufen, sind auch sofort massiv hochgegangen.
Ja, die möchte ich übrigens auch in die Liste der möglichen Täter mal aufnehmen. Schließlich schreiben die angeblich auch jede Menge Viren. Um ihre Virenschutzprogramme zu verkaufen, gibt es Leute, die sagen das zumindest.
Warum lassen sie sich in Mercedesen durch die Gegend fahren? Immer noch die Frage an unsere Hörer, wer könnte denn diese Denial-of-Service-Attacken gemacht haben? Ich sag nochmal die Nummer, bzw. lasse ich die von einer Frauenstimme sagen.
Moment.
Warum kommt die nicht?
Weil ich blöd bin.
Ich war es.
Sind die weggelaufen?
Nee, hier funktioniert gerade meine Technik nicht. Das ist ja furchtbar. 0331 70 97 110. Wenn es 0 hat, habe ich nicht eine wunderbare Frauenstimme?
Also nehm ihn rein.
Hallo? Da rief ich einen Hacker am Telefon. Hallo, Ortmann. Ortmann?
Ja, also ich war es nicht sein, ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen.
Oh Entschuldigung.
Ja, na ich kann mir das halt auch vorstellen, dass es jetzt so irgendwelche waren und ich hab's mal probiert mit so einem Freund, aber das hat halt irgendwie nicht ganz geklappt, aber ich finde halt es ziemlich einfach jetzt so irgendwelche Viren irgendwie so zu verschicken und so. Also ich weiß nicht, es ist ziemlich einfach so.
Also du sagst, das hat nicht geklappt, aber es ist einfach.
Nein, ja, also jetzt nicht jetzt so, was die anderen halt gemacht haben. Das haben wir halt probiert, aber es hat nicht geklappt, also es ist nicht einfach, sondern jetzt irgendwelche Viren zu verschicken oder irgendwelche Dateien zu löschen. Oder ich weiß nicht, also mit dem Freund haben wir zum Beispiel so, es hat uns ein Lehrer mal seine E-Mail-Adresse gegeben, und dann haben wir halt so seine IP-Card geknackt. Und dann haben wir mal so einen Trojaner halt auf so irgendeine Festplatte so geschickt. Und das ist halt, also ich finde das ist ziemlich einfach so.
Das bezeichnest du als hacken?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Naja, ich meine, es gibt halt heute...
Also das heißt nicht das Cracken, weil ich zerstöre diese Appellen. Also ich schau mich auf seinen Rechner um, und wenn ich Lust hab, kann ich das zerstören. Und ich bin so, also ich mach es halt nicht so, aber ich finde es ist halt ziemlich einfach. Also man kann es halt leicht machen.
Also ich denke, wir sind alle mit dir, weil du bist schließlich Schüler und es geht hier um einen Lehrer. Und deswegen wollen wir dich jetzt hier mal nicht moralisch aburteilen. Das ist bei deinem Notweg mit den nächsten Hörern machen, oder so.
Ja, dann nehmen wir doch mal den nächsten dran. Entschuldige, Anne.
Ich find das bloß immer relativ lustig, dass immer viele so diese Verschwörungstheorien am Start haben, die alle zu viel oder wenig ausgelesen haben. Es gab schon viele Angriffe gegen große Rechner. Nehmen wir 1998 die Pentagon-Attacke von drei Leuten.
Ja, das war auch während der Budgetverhandlungen im US-Senat. Aber red weiter.
Ja, genau. Ich find das bloß ziemlich unterhaltsam, weil immer sagen, ja, Verschwörung, NSA, tralala. Da haben sich wahrscheinlich bloß viele Leute gedacht, oder so ein interner Kreis gedacht, jetzt könnten wir vielleicht mal Yahoo knacken. Das haben schon viele Leute probiert. Es wollten auch Leute sagen, hey, befreien wir Kevin Mitnick und jetzt implantieren wir eine logische Bombe in Yahoo. Hat ja auch nicht geklappt, aber es sind so Ziele, die groß sind und die viel Aufmerksamkeit darin im Grunde genommen. Aber so, dass diese ganze Verschwörungstheorie, ich glaube, die ist von Arsch.
Naja, aber Leute, die viel Aufmerksamkeit erregen wollen, die sagen das auch immer und die machen nicht einfach was platt und melden sich nicht.
Vielleicht wollte man nur platt machen.
Du meinst, der reine, ungetrübte Kaputt will Spaß?
Ja, es gibt viele vorpuppertiere Picklige, die an ihrem Rechner sitzen. Ich habe von einem gehört, mit der Festplatte seines Lehrers. Ich finde es unterhaltsam, dass viele Leute sagen, ich habe jetzt einen Trojaner installiert, jetzt bin ich drauf rumgegeistert, jetzt bin ich ein Hacker, jetzt bin ich ein Held. Das finde ich traurig, ganz ehrlich. Dafür gibt es sicherlich noch Leute, man kann Jugendliche, ich bin auch erst 20 im Gottes Willen, aber man kann Kiddies leichter zu motivieren, hey komm, wir machen jetzt hier Huplatt oder wir machen CNN-Platt, das geht ganz schnell. Also motivieren kann man viele ganz, ganz fix. Wenn da zwei Leute sitzen, die sagen, hey komm, jetzt machen wir das richtig fertig. Leute findet man immer, vor allem genügend.
Ja klar, die Frage ist ja, was willst du mit der Energie der jungen Menschen irgendwie machen? Und wenn das Internet so anfällig ist, hat es das Internet dann anders verdient? Ich meine, wenn ich irgendwie 14, wie er uns schlechte Laune hätte, dann würde ich vielleicht auch Unsinn machen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es darum schlechte Laune geht. Ich meine, da sind ja, wenn man den größeren Firmen glauben kann, dann sind denen Millionen Flöten gegangen. Ich habe heute einen schlechten Tag.
Was heißt Millionen Flöten gegangen? Die hatten halt Ausfälle von irgendwelchen Werbebannern, mit denen sie normalerweise die Menschheit betrügen. Du hast sicherlich fest, da geht es um Geld. Da kann man uns auch in eine moralische Position stellen und sagen, das ist nicht schlimm. Aber wenn es 14-Jährige schaffen, die Weltwirtschaft in den Dimensionen zu schädigen, dann ist vielleicht auch da mit der Struktur irgendwas nicht richtig.
Ja, es ist traurig, dass das, man weiß es nicht, dass es 14-Jährige waren. Man kann es vermuten, weil, wie gesagt, leicht zu motivieren sind. Tralala. Aber es ist richtig, dass eine Gruppe von Leuten, man kann ja nicht sagen, wie viele es waren, die Weltwirtschaft auf jeden Fall schädigen können. Das ist auf jeden Fall traurig. So was, das in diesem Maße überhaupt möglich war.
Also ich find das lustig. Ich stell mich jetzt mal gegen dich. Ich find das lustig.
Ja mein Gott, gegen mich? Ach scheiß mal, mach doch.
Was ist denn daran so traurig? Soll ich jetzt über die Jugendlichen weinen oder soll ich über die armen Computer weinen, die irgendwie gerade mal ein bisschen in die Richtung schieben, statt in die Richtung zu schieben? Soll ich jetzt irgendwie hier tatsächlich, also traurig finde ich ein bisschen vermessen. Ich finde es genauso vermessen wie den Begriff Cyberterrorismus, weil Terrorismus, da sterben normalerweise Leute und hier sind nicht mal Computer gestorben. Nein, sie waren nur ein bisschen überlastet.
Ja, ist doch bei der Anfang. Wenn das jetzt schon möglich ist, was wird denn erstmal passieren? Vielleicht war es ja bloß eine Probe, auf Exempel. Mal testen, was so möglich ist. Vielleicht sind jetzt größere Rechner dran.
Ja gut, aber nur davon, dass Werbebanner nicht eingeblendet werden, blutet keiner.
Die Werbebanner gibt es doch eigentlich gar nicht. Im Grunde genommen kann man sagen, es war nur ein Test.
Aber wofür?
Für was Größeres?
Ja, und was?
Wer weiß das schon, ja genau.
Also Krankenhaus sind noch nicht auf IP-Ebene.
Aber es wird gerade eine Studie, die behauptet, dass Krankenhäuser mehr Internet machen sollen, weil sie dadurch viel sparen können. Und dafür brauchen sie eine Standkarte. Aber die Frage ist, ist das Problem dadurch gelöst, dass es solche Angriffe nicht gibt, oder ist das Problem jetzt in dem Moment gelöst, weil die Computer sicher sind? Also wir wollen jetzt, also ich denke, wir nehmen deine Eingabe jetzt mal auf und da halten wir uns ein bisschen im Hinterkopf. Wir wollten nämlich hier gerade ein kleines Rollenspiel spielen, um auch mal technisch noch mal kurz ins Detail zu kommen. Ich hab jetzt hier gerade eindeutige Handbewegungen gezeigt.
Ich sag Christian gerade mal Tschüss. Danke für deinen Anruf.
Andis Rollenspielidee ist, dass ich jetzt den Pluto hacke.
Aber Dui hat ihn hammer vergessen.
Ganz genau.
Nein, also ich hatte mir das eigentlich so vorgestellt, dass du Dui jetzt mal sagst, du willst ihn jetzt platt machen. Nehmen wir mal an. Scheinlich. Dem ist jetzt sein Computer, der betreibt auch noch so ein Service. Das ist irgendwie so ein Service-Domain. Die hört mit dem Namen Service auf. Und da kriegt man alles mögliche, aber nicht den Service, den es verspricht. Das ist also wirklich ein Ziel. Das war, weil du mal Hunger hattest. Da werden einem Nahrungsmittel versprochen, die man nicht bekommt. Man bekommt auf diesem Server alles, aber nicht das, was es verspricht.
Das ist so zum Fein.
Ja, und ich bin jetzt total sauer auf dem Pluto, weil er mir irgendwie nichts zu essen geliefert hat. Dann könnte ich, das ist der klassische Denial-of-Service-Eingriff, einfach jetzt zu ihm hingehen und ihn irgendwie belästigen. Und der Gag bei...
Ja, das tust du ja schon.
Ja, also haben wir uns noch nach der Sendung zweitgelegt. Distributed Denial-of-Service ist jetzt viel schlauer, man lässt andere für sich erarbeiten. Das heißt, ich muss nur andere Leute finden und die überreden, im Pluto auf den Senkel zu gehen.
Ja, ich biete mich an.
Also jetzt mal irgendwie zur technischen Seite zurück. Distributed Denial-of-Service funktioniert kurz gesagt so, dass man jede Menge Anderleuts Rechner hackt. Das erfolgt größtenteils automatisch. So richtig gute Anderleuts Rechner Hack-Programme brauchen dafür irgendwie vier Sekunden oder so, bis sie drin sind und ihre Software installiert haben und wieder draußen sind. Und wenn man davon dann, sagen wir mal, 1000 Stück aufgemacht hat und da eine Software drauf installiert, mit der man den Rechner fernsteuern kann, dann kann man zu Hause an seinem PC sitzen, ganz bequem, und die Leistung von diesen 1000 Rechnern alle irgendwie zum Pluto schicken. Und natürlich nicht nur Leistung, sondern auch Datenmüll oder andere Belästigungen. So einfach ist Distributed Denial of Service. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass man mit ein bisschen Mühe diese 1000 Rechner natürlich rausfinden kann. Aber man weiß nicht, wer diese Rechner gehackt hat und wer die ferngesteuert hat.
Wird das nicht irgendwo protokolliert denn?
Naja, es gibt irgendwie noch leider keinen Protokollstandard, wie man unberechtigte Zugriffe auf Rechner protokolliert.
Na gut, aber ich kann noch sehen, von welcher IP-Adresse aus dieses Ich-gehe-dir-auf-den-Sack-Programm gekommen ist.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass die Angehalfer ja nicht so blöd sind, dass wenn sie sich nicht entdecken lassen wollen, dass sie dann irgendwie die Logfiles nicht als allererstes löschen, beziehungsweise die Diskussion ausschalten. Nee, ist schon in Ordnung. Die aktuelle IP-Nummer ist halt, auch wenn dir jemand da irgendwie reingeht, irgendwie relativ uninteressant, weil wenn der ein bisschen routen kann, und wenn der so ein bisschen routert auf so einem Uni-Rechner, dann hat er dazwischen plötzlich irgendwie ein nicht routbares Internet, das kannst du dann nicht mehr tracen, da weißt du nicht, wo die IP-Nummer herkommt.
Hauptproblem ist diese Rechner, die man für sowas ganz leicht hacken kann. Die sind natürlich auch Rechner, um die sich keiner so recht kümmert, wo die Sicherheit eh nicht so hoch ist, und dann ist da auch keine Software drauf installiert, mit der man nachträglich sowas gut feststellen kann.
Gibt es da so Beispiele von Firmen, die ihre Rechner so laufen lassen und laufen lassen?
Man muss ja dazu sagen, damit diese Denial-of-Service hier richtig gut funktionierte, hat man sich ja spezielle Computer ausgesucht. Der Angreifer oder die Angreiferin, wer weiß, war ein bisschen faul oder hat es sich effektiv gestaltet. Das heißt, es wurden Computer genommen, die eine hohe Anbindung ans Internet haben, also beispielsweise Universitäten, so ab 34 Megabit aufwärts. Und auch Universitäten stehen nicht immer in dem Ruf, ihre Computerwissenschaftsletzte mitzukontrollieren, oder auch nur kontrollieren zu können, weil da gibt es diese Studentengesocks, was oftmals mehr davon versteht als die Systemmitreiber.
Außerdem haben die Universitäten schon immer die Einstellung, unsere Computer sind zum Benutzen und nicht zum Sicher machen.
Also es gab ja, als diese Geschichte hier durch die Media ging, da gab es ab und zu so Agenturmeldungen, ja, die Universität von Michigan sagt, sie waren es vielleicht, dann kam irgendwie auch eine norddeutsche Universität, ja, wir waren es vielleicht, und dann hat sich das überschlagen. Also letztendlich war die Öffentlichkeit wahrscheinlich, die es dieses Jahr gar nicht verstanden hat, ein bisschen in dem Glauben, man könnte die Leute jetzt finden, aber das ist eben nicht so.
Naja, fast ja schon. Wir hatten jetzt in Deutschland so einen Fall, beim Kölner Internetprovider NetColon, die haben angeblich wirklich jemanden gefunden. Die sind auch von der Universität aus angegriffen worden, Mannheim. Und die sagen halt, sie haben den rausgefunden, der das war.
Also das war aber komisch. Vielleicht kannst du die Geschichte nochmal in Detail erzählen, weil ich kann dir nur sagen, es gab diese weltweiten Attacken und auf einmal waren die Zeitungen voll davon und dann kamen diese Deutschen und ich dachte schon, hey, die kennt keiner. Das ist geile Reklame jetzt. Kann man sich irgendwie sagen, wir auch betroffen und überhaupt. Wie könnte das Werbung gewesen sein? Wie würdest du die einschätzen?
Ja, die Sache ist schon echt komisch gelaufen. Einmal, dass sie so wirklich nach dem Motto, keiner findet die Hacker, aber wir. Und sie haben ein paar Tage rausgetan, dass sie Probleme mit der Technik haben und irgendwie neue Telefonanlage installieren und es könnte zu Störungen kommen. Und dann haben sie diese Mitteilungen zum Teil sogar in ihren Informationsforen wieder gelöscht. Und dann plötzlich gesagt, ja die Störungen waren da, weil ein Hacker da war. Und alles, was sie dazu so gesagt haben, macht relativ wenig Sinn. Also mit einem einzelnen kleinen Uni-Rechner, einen Internet-Provider, der irgendwie fünf unabhängige Internet-Anbindungen hat, lahm zu legen, klingt recht unrealistisch. Und der Typ, der jetzt so der Sündenbock sein soll, sicherlich kein Engel, aber dass der da die technischen Fähigkeiten hat, ist doch ziemlich zweifelhaft. Und angeblich hat er auch wiederum ganz anderen Kölner Internet-Provider angegriffen. Also das macht alles ganz, ganz wenig Sinn.
Ich meine, machen solche Angriffe Sinn, aber gut.
Naja, diesmal ging es darum, ob die Pressemitteilung von NetColon Sinn macht, oder ob die nur sagen wollen, wir auch.
Gut, aber die Frage war jetzt nochmal ganz kurz, ok, du hackst jetzt also irgendwelche Computer, und diese Computer, die machen dann Bluetooth-Dingenserver, der sowieso den Service, den er anbietet, nicht hält, platt. Ja, soweit waren wir jetzt, und jetzt sagen wir, woran liegt es? Woran liegt es, dass das geht? Ok, er kann sich nicht schützen, er ist ja nur das Opfer. Du kannst jetzt mal bitte, kannst du ein bisschen wehleidig gucken oder so? Entschuldigung, ich vergeiß, wir sind im Radio.
Die Frage ist... Also irgendein Privat-Sender hat mal einen sehr schönen Vergleich gemacht, meiner Meinung nach. Und zwar haben die gesagt, Internet, Datenautobahn kann jeder verstehen. Und so ein Rechner steht an der Autobahnabfahrt. Und man schickt da jetzt ganz viele Autos hin, gefälschte Datenpakete sozusagen, oder Datenpakete, und sagt, fahrt mal an der Abfahrt runter. Und das ist eine riesen Verstopfung.
Also wann stellt du Schilder auf, meinst du?
Nee, man stellt nicht, man schickt die Autos los. Sozusagen wenn man eine Autofabrik hat, oder weiß nicht, wie sie sich das vorstellen. Und der Gag ist jetzt, natürlich wenn man selber am Ende der Abfahrt ist, kann man die Autos schon irgendwie gar nichts machen, weil alles verstopft ist. Man könnte ja vielleicht am Autobahnkreuz davor alle Autos mit dem Kennzeichen, wo man weiß, dass die irgendwie eh Unsinn vorhaben, schon nicht durchlassen. Das Problem ist, dass halt alle Autos auch noch gefälschte Autonummern haben. So haben die das dargestellt.
Und dass es nicht nur ein Kreuz ist, sondern dass es mehrere Kreuzes sind, und dass es so viele Autos sind, dass im Zweifelsfall auch die Kreuze, wenn du es gut machst, irgendwie zu sind. Und selbst wenn du es schaffst, das Kreuz zu sperren, dann hast du die Autobahn einfach immer noch voll. Die Viecher sind einfach da. Dann hast du zwar den Nachschub abgestaltet, aber es ist halt immer noch ein Riesenbechlein.
Eine bestimmte Menge Straße verträgt doch nur eine bestimmte Menge Autos.
Und das Einzige, was helfen würde, wäre sie an der Stelle, wo sie auf der Autobahn fahren, nicht reinzulassen, aber bis man die Stelle gefunden hat.
Sind sie schon drauf.
Da musst du auch noch unterscheiden, welche von diesen Autos du haben möchtest und welche nicht. Weil das Problem ist, wenn du jetzt sag mal mal, du bist jetzt in der Augenweide, bei dem Vergleich zu bleiben, du bist bei einer Autotankstelle, so einer Autobahnraststätte und ein paar davon sind deine Kunden und der Rest macht nur Stress, weil da irgendwie alles verstopft. Dann musst du erstmal irgendwie 500 Kilometer vorher rauskriegen, ob die jetzt in 500 Kilometern Benzin brauchen werden.
Ja, nein.
Und da fängt dann halt irgendwie das Problem an.
Naja und du musst sicher sein können, dass sie nicht vor 500 Kilometern gelogen haben. Das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Ja, das große Problem ist eben, dass jeder irgendwie an sein Datenpaket die Autonummer seiner Wahl dran schreiben kann. Also, die IP-Adressen vom Absender sind ganz leicht zu fälschen. Und deshalb kannst du nie sicher sagen, dass dein Datenpaket wirklich nicht vorauskommt.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja nur ein Problem im Kleinen. Weil, dass das jeder machen kann, ist zweifelsohne richtig. Aber es tut ja nicht jeder. Und wenn einer so eine normale Denial-of-Service fährt, dann ist der normalerweise relativ schnell zu lokalisieren, weil da gibt es eine tatsächliche Ursprungsadresse, die zwar gefälschte Autonummern sozusagen losschickt, aber die kann man dann irgendwie verhaften und kann dann irgendwie die Männer mit den Limousinen und den Maschinen gewähren oder was auch immer als Problemlösung akquirieren. Das ist aber relativ schwierig, also wenn du es smooth machst, also das was die Tools auch mitmachen, also ein Paket wird von einem losgeschickt, von vielen vervielfacht und wieder zurückgeschickt, dann hast du ein Paket und musst wissen, woher dieses eine Paket kam. Das heißt, du musst die gesamte Strecke dieses einen Pakete zurückfolgen. Wenn du jetzt überlegst, du hast da einen Router, der im Internet steht, das ist so, wie jedes Auto durchzählen, das am Kamener Kreuz innerhalb von zwei Wochen durchgefahren ist. Innerhalb von zwei Stunden.
Vergiss es einfach. Na ja, also sie haben es ja als der erste große Smurf...
Gut, also, wollen wir das Internet jetzt begraben, oder? Na, weil du ein Loch hast, das groß genug ist. Das war jetzt eine Frage.
Er hat schon ein schwarzes Loch bei, vielleicht, aber...
Also bei dem ersten Smurfangriff haben sie es ja geschafft. Die haben damals den Internetprovider in New York Panics lahmgelegt. Drei Tage lang, und nach drei Tagen haben sie dann sozusagen alle Autobahnkreuze abgeklappert gehabt, bis sie gefunden haben, wo die Datenpakete kamen.
Ja, der Typ war halt zu doof, irgendwie schnell genug abzuhauen. Weil du kannst es halt nicht im Nachhinein vorfolgen. Wenn er es immer weiter macht, dann kannst du halt immer mehr Polizisten an immer mehr Kreuzungen stellen und die gucken halt, wo die roten Autos herkommen. Aber wenn das eine kurze Aktion ist, wo jemand mal vor drei Stunden einen Schnack macht, dann hast du im Nachhinein wenig Chancen. Während der Aktion kannst du, das stimmt.
Apropos Schnack, machen wir mal Musik.
Wir müssen auch irgendwie mal wieder den Pfad finden. Wollten wir nicht auch noch darüber reden, wie man das Internet sicher machen könnte? Bei genauerer Überlegung hat sich das jetzt schon als Illusion rausgestellt.
Naja, man kann auch überlegen, ob das denn schlimm ist, wenn ab und zu mal irgendwie ein paar Server aus sind.
Das ist sicherlich eine interessante Frage. Aber überantworten wir gleich. Der letzte Mittwoch im Monat Chaosradio, Ausgabe 47. Wir haben auch wieder ein paar Leute am Telefon, noch aus der letzten Stunde, von unserem Pfaden aus der letzten Stunde. Mario, bist du noch da? Ne, Mario ist nicht mehr da. Das ist eigentlich vergleichsweise schade. Dann nehmen wir mal Thomas.
Thomas?
Irgendwie, die wollen eigentlich nicht uns reden.
Das ist echt unser Hörer.
Die hassen uns.
Ein Letzter noch.
Eine kleine Denial auf Schöne.
Steffen.
Von unserer Hörer, alle time out. Wer war's? Ich bin am Apparat, ja. Nee, also ich hab da eigentlich so eher zwei Theorien. Zum einen diese NSA-Geschichte, naja möglich, aber vielleicht sollte man auch mal in eine andere Richtung denken. Wie wär's denn mit Carnegie und Ritchie? Und wer ist das? Na die Herren, die Unix ausgepasst wird haben.
Die waren das.
Du meinst mit ihrem Computer-Bug, den sie vor 30 Jahren eingebaut haben, haben sie jetzt das Internet verpasst.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, die haben sich doch schon mal so diesen Gag erlaubt, so zu meinen, dass C eigentlich aus einer völlig lustigen Fasson heranstanden ist und das eigentlich verboten sein sollte. Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass die wieder auf irgendeiner einsamen Insel sitzen und sich denken Mensch, machen wir mal einen Spaß, machen da mal was platt. So halt auf die Schiene. Und die haben es dann auch nicht nötig an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen und zu sagen, hä, wir waren verpasst.
Du machst den reich. Ja, also wenn man mal die Namen weglässt, dann ist da vielleicht sogar ein bisschen was dran, so im Sinne von die Hacker als Gruppe, so im Sinne von wenn man etwas haben möchte, was halt schnell mal pinkt irgendwie und dann geht man halt weg, dann ist man da vielleicht schon mit in der...
Ich hab das auch nicht verstanden.
Kannst du nochmal kurz den vollständigen deutschen Satz reden, der eventuell auch einen Sinn ergibt? Ich kanns nochmal probieren irgendwie, kleines Reboot, Schnick.
Warte mal, ich mach kurz laut.
Jetzt.
Na im Prinzip so die Leute, die so am Internet halt programmiert haben, im Sinne von wer halt TCPIP erfunden hat, wer halt diese ganzen Routing-Protokolle, wer halt dieses ganze Teil irgendwie mitgegründet hat, Cunningham Merchie mit irgendwie die ersten C und Linux und danach dann die Leute, die TCPIP gemacht haben, die im Prinzip da irgendwo eine Blümchenwiese hatten, um dieses schöne Wort nochmal zu zitieren, wo man halt so ein bisschen gespielt hat, wo man sich gefreut hat, wenn der erste von zwei Routern tatsächlich gepinkt hat und wo so Sachen wie irgendwie Erkennung dessen, wer da pinkt, auch im Nachhinein nicht bedacht wurden. Also wo halt irgendwie schön war, wenn läuft und wenn läuft, dann macht man das nächste, weil viele Features ist immer gut und...
Naja, den Wannabend war das von Anfang an auch klar. Es gibt ja gerade von Cunningham and Ritchie diese Sache, wo sie im Prinzip das Publikum auf einer Konferenz fragen, woher wisst ihr, dass wir nicht ein trojanisches Pferd in Unix eingebaut haben. Und dann haben die Leute gesagt, ja wir gucken uns den Quellcode an und kompilieren das neu. Dann haben wir gesehen, dass nicht im Quellcode drin war. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja und wenn wir in den Compiler jetzt das trojanische Pferd eingebaut haben, dann haben wir im Quellcode vom Compiler nachgeguckt und übersetzen den neu. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja und wenn wir jetzt den Compiler so modifiziert haben, dass er bei jedem selber neu übersetzt und wieder das trojanische Pferd eingebaut. Und das kann man dann noch ein bisschen weiterspinnen und damit ist im Prinzip ganz klar gesagt, Sicherheit gibt es nicht.
Okay, dann können wir jetzt mal überleiten.
Steffen, danke für deinen Anruf.
Überleiten wohin?
Ja, in die zweite Stunde. Wir sind sozusagen schwer in einer von uns vorher ersonnenen Struktur und wollten über eine Methode reden, wie man möglicherweise die Verbindlichkeit in den Kommunikationsprozessen im Netz sozusagen ein bisschen steigern kann. Wobei es gibt da sehr unterschiedliche Vorstellungen, selbst wenn man sich darauf einigt, dass digitale Signaturen, also eine Methode, um sozusagen den Absender irgendwie klar zu machen, um zu sagen, ich war es, womit eben aber noch nicht unbedingt gesagt wird, ich war es mit Personalausweisnummer so und so und so. Oder ob ich einfach sage, ich bin Donald Duck, ich nenne mich im Netz Donald Duck. Und ihr könnt sicher gehen durch digitale Signaturen, dass alles, was unter dem Namen Donald Duck kommt, auch wirklich von mir kommt. Damit wisst ihr zwar noch nicht, wer ich bin, aber ihr könnt sicher sein, dass ich mich schon anständig benehme. Und wenn nicht, dann darf ich eben nicht mehr oder dann muss ich mir ein neues Zordernamen suchen oder was auch immer. Das ist nicht sehr auf Menschen bezogen, aber die direkte Überarbeitung sind da vielleicht zu Themen wie PKCX, also das, was gerade z.B. von Cisco und ein paar anderen. Hey cool, willst du vielleicht Abkürzung erläutern?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich bitte was?
Also es ist im Prinzip, um das so grob zu formulieren, ein Standard für die Verteilung von Schlüsseln, also von sozusagen digitalen Ausweisen, mit denen man sich gegenüber einem anderen authentifizieren, sprich zeigen kann, dass man wirklich der ist, der man vorgibt zu sein. Und das wird gerade von einem sehr großen Hersteller von Internet-Routern, also von den Dingern, die die Pakete tatsächlich transportieren, die dafür zuständig sind, dass PCNA von dir zu deinem Server kommt und zurück gepusht, womit tatsächlich dann auch eine gewisse Authentifizierung von einzelnen Kommunikationsteilnehmern auf IP-Ebene, also auf Ebene der einzelnen verschickten Päckchen gemacht werden kann, weil die Authentifizierung in dem Fall nicht so sehr zwischen Menschen läuft, also nicht zwischen Leuten, die einen Perso haben, sondern zwischen Maschinen, wie sie sagen, du, diesen Router, den kenne ich, dessen Public Key habe ich und er hat das unterschrieben, er macht jetzt diese Verbindung zu mir auf, dem glaube ich das, der darf schicken. Der, dessen Public Key ich nicht habe oder der sich nicht richtig darstellen kann. Aber das klingt schon ein bisschen so, als würdest du damit sagen, dass wenn die Maschinen erst mal untereinander verbindliche Kommunikation führen, dann ist das Problem ja nur noch der Mensch und dann komme ich irgendwann vor wie im Matrix, glaube ich. Ach, das Problem ist auf jeden Fall der Mensch, das ist keine Frage.
Muss ich denn nicht das Endgerät, also den Rechner, der bei mir zu Hause steht, den muss ich doch irgendwie legitimieren dann auch?
Na, das tust du ja sowieso, weil dein Provider gibt dir eine IP-Nummer dafür, dass du ihm ein Passwort gibst oder eine Telefonnummer, mit der du halt einwählst, je nachdem, was du da gerade machst. Das heißt also diese letzte Endstelle, wenn du jetzt wirklich Surfer bist oder so, die ist authentifiziert und was halt dazwischen kommt irgendwie, ist halt nicht authentifiziert, sprich die Router schicken halt hin und her und es soll auch Provider geben, die ihre Routing-Tabellen irgendwie ohne Rückfrage vom Upling-Provider, also von demjenigen, der das noch dickere Internet hat und für den Provider zur Verfügung stellt, einfach akzeptieren und einfach mal glauben, weil sie den Typen, der da dransitzt, halt irgendwie kennen und weil er gut ist irgendwie. Und diese Protokolle versuchen halt diesem Wildfuchs, dieser Blümchen-Wiese einen Riegel vorzuschieben, dass man halt sagt, okay, auch meine Blümchen-Wiese lasse ich nur Pakete von Leuten, die ich kenne. Das heißt also nicht von Leuten in dem Fall, sondern von Firmen, die ihre Router mit Zerts ausgestattet haben, also mit Schlüsselpaaren, mit denen sie sich gegenüber den Routern von anderen Leuten authentifizieren können. Und damit hat man schon die Anfänge von solchen Strukturen. Das ist jetzt seit zwei, drei Jahren so ein bisschen in Arbeit, das wird im Moment gerade ein bisschen gepusht. Gerade halt auch von einem sehr großen Hersteller aus der Richtung Umhalt, irgendwie, wie ich den Namen nicht mehr mal sage, da Verbindlichkeit...
Siemens ist es nicht, ne?
Nein, es ist auch nicht irgendwie von Jutu und Symbas auch nicht und Symbas auch nicht und... Aber sozusagen das Konzept der digitalen Signaturen, sollten wir vielleicht noch mal kurz etwas grundlegender erläutern? Ja, so kurz die... Weil da gibt es ja zumindest zwei Konzepte. Nein, es gibt erstmal ein Konzept, auf dem das Ganze aufbaut. Also eine Menge Abkürzungen, die heute Abend vielleicht auch noch fallen werden, fangen mit PKC an, wie zum Beispiel gerade PKC-X oder PKC-S. Dieses PKC steht für Public Key Cryptography. Das heißt, es gibt einen... Übersetzt ist das dann die Verschlüsselung mit öffentlichen Schlüsseln. Also die asymmetrische Verschlüsselung, was so viel heißt wie du kannst mir, wenn du meinen öffentlichen Schlüssel hast, etwas schicken, aber ich kann es nur mit meinem Geheim entschlüsseln. Und andersrum kann ich dir einen Text schicken, der mit meinem geheimen Schlüssel signiert ist. Das heißt, ich lasse eine Prüfsumme über den Text laufen. Okay, jetzt sind wir bei 10, 3 Vierteln in 30 Sekunden.
Weißt du, jetzt sind wir bei 10, 3 Vierteln.
Also nehmen wir mal an, ich schick dir einen Text und dessen Prüfsumme ist 42. Und diese 42, die verschlüssel ich jetzt mit meinem geheimen Schlüssel und du willst überprüfen, ist dieser Text von mir oder hat jemand zwischendurch in dem Text irgendwas drin geändert. Und wir haben da auf einmal einen Haufen Kumis drinstehen.
Du verschlüsselst also deinem, deinem.
Also nehmen wir mal an, ich schick ihm eine Blümchenwiese. Bei ihm kommt aber ein Haufen Kumis an. Und jetzt will er wissen, hat Andi mir Blümchenwiese geschickt oder hat er mir Kumis geschickt. So und bevor ich ihn da schicke, hab ich da mal kurz ein Programm rüber laufen, das ist eine Prüfsumme berechnet und die ist sagen wir 42. Diese Prüfsumme, nur die Prüfsumme, nicht den Text, verschlüssel ich jetzt mit meinem geheimen Schlüssel, da muss ich meine Passfails eingeben und den ganzen Schotter und schick ihm das. Und dann kann er anhand meines öffentlichen Schutzes, den ja alle haben, er auch, eben überprüfen, stimmt die Prüfsumme, verschlüsselt sozusagen damit überein oder ist die damit nicht hineinkommen. Und dann weiß er, er hat mir die Blümchen, wie sie geschickt, oder er hat mir den Kumist geschickt und kann entsprechend reagieren. Ja, also ich versuch das nochmal kurz so von vorne ein bisschen langsamer zu machen, im Sinne von irgendwie, also das worüber wir hier alle reden irgendwie und ist halt Verschlüsselung irgendwie, was Andi gerade gesagt hat, asymmetrische. Das heißt, es gibt zwei Schlüssel. Bis vor etwa 20 Jahren, bis die Engländer das erfunden haben mit der asymmetrischen Verschlüsselung, gab es immer nur symmetrische Verschlüsselung. Das bedeutet, Symmetrie bedeutet, auf beiden Seiten von etwas ist das Gleiche. Asymmetrie bedeutet, auf beiden Seiten von etwas ist etwas unterschiedliches. Das heißt, wenn man asymmetrische Verschlüsselung macht, dann hat man einen Schlüssel, der auf beiden Seiten bekannt sein muss. Und wenn man asymmetrische macht, dann hat man halt zwei Schlüssel, von denen der eine den einen hat und der andere den anderen, sprich den Public und den Security. Dann lassen wir euch das glaube ich erstmal verdauen an euren Radios, machen ein bisschen Musik und dann erklären wir euch, was digitale Signaturen nach den Vorstellungen des Gesetzgebers sind.
Vorher noch für die Paranoika ein Einwurf. Es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, das gibt es nicht seit 20 Jahren, sondern seit 80 Jahren und die Geheimdienste haben es uns nur nicht erzählt.
Nee, das muss man gar nicht paranoidisch erklären, weil der Typ, der es für den englischen Geheimdiensten entwickelt hat... Was war jetzt schon ein paar Nachfragen zur Musik? Macht einfach, Alter, wisst ihr, oder die sucht wahrscheinlich eure Wahl, digitalsport.mp3. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo es herkommt, wer das gesagt hat.
Da muss das ganze Teil, diese 800 Millionen Minuten, die da laufen, oder?
350 sind's insgesamt, oder so.
Digitalsport.mp3.
Ja, keine Ahnung, wo es herkommt. Also wenn derjenige, wenn irgendjemand weiß, wo es herkommt, so gerne auch mal mail an Chaosradio, oder BRD, äh, mich antusieren, sind wahrscheinlich Fliegeleute. Wir wollten jetzt mal ganz kurz ein ganz einfaches Beispiel erst mal wählen, um zu erklären, was digitale Signaturen nach den Vorstellungen des Gesetzgebers sind. Also ganz grob soll es die Möglichkeit sein, das was man bisher durch eine Unterschrift zum Beispiel auf einem Vertrag machen musste, eben elektronisch zu machen.
Also eigentlich wollten wir nicht das zuerst erklären, sondern erstmal das...
Nein, das wollten wir nicht. Okay, aber erstmal, was soll es sein? Die Unterschrift, wozu dient die, um einen Vertrag zu schließen? Nehmen wir also an, ich will... So, und jetzt geht's los.
Also erstmal hast du schon falsch angefangen, Anni. Du brauchst keine Unterschrift, um einen Vertrag zu schließen. Das muss man erstmal erklären.
Okay, der Kaufmann jetzt bitte.
Nein, der Kaufmann in Deutschland kann jeder irgendwie einen Vertrag schließen, in dem er die Händchen schüttelt und sich in den Arm nimmt und gut ist. In anderen Ländern ist das zum Teil so, dass man irgendwie, wenn man mehr als ein Brötchen kaufen will, was Unterschriebenes braucht. Aber hier reicht das auch. Du kannst per Telefon Pizza bestellen oder bei Neckarmann. Du brauchst also nichts Unterschriebenes. Das muss man ganz klar gesagt sein und das Internet ändert daran auch nicht.
Gut, aber dann sag mir, warum irgendwie veranstaltet, ich meine damals war es noch Budgas und dem seine Motive, können wir jetzt nach diesem Spenden-Skandal sowieso irgendwie alle etwas besser verstehen oder in Frage stellen. Aber ursprünglich gab es da mal so eine Akit-Pop-Abteilung, die hat gesagt, wir wollen Rechtssicherheit im Internet und wir wollen die Möglichkeit eben elektronische Verträge abzuschließen und dazu braucht man angeblich eine digitale Signatur. Jetzt sagst du, braucht man gar nicht, es reicht eigentlich auch, wenn die sich alle mal in den Arm nehmen würden. Ich würde es natürlich auch gut finden, wenn die sich in den Arm nehmen würden, bloß das in den Arm nehmen Konzept, das ist ja ein sogenanntes Vertrauenskonzept und das worauf sich die Juristerei so im Allgemeinen begründet ist ja Misstrauen. Also man schließt ja deswegen Verträge miteinander ab, weil man sich nicht traut. Man gründet deswegen Staaten und Gesetze, weil man sich nicht traut. Und jetzt sind wir natürlich eigentlich in einer Diskussion, wo wir uns mit einer Scheiße beschäftigen, die auf Misstrauen basiert. Also schon mit einer Materie sollten wir erst mal sagen, also ob sie stinkt oder nicht, da kommen wir dann später zu. Aber ich meine, wir haben jetzt einen Juristen hier, was soll's? Also würdest du denen zustimmen, dass es hier um Misstrauen geht? Dann mal los. Also du sagst jetzt gerade in den Arm nehmen. Was ist das Problem? Man hat sich halt mal in den Arm genommen, man hat einen Vertrag geschlossen und ein Monat später behauptet eine von den beiden Parteien, dass sie auf den Arm genommen wurde. Und dann ist halt die Frage der Beweishaftigkeit, also wie kann man nachweisen, dass der andere einmal umarmt hat und jetzt irgendwie auf den Arm klatscht. Ich meine, wenn wir jetzt noch ein Beispiel nehmen, da haben wir diesen Onkel Enzo als Integrationsfigur in die ich bestellende Pizza und ich weiß genau, in 30 Minuten ist sie da und wenn nicht, dann kommt Onkel Enzo und regelt das. Und da habe ich einfach eine klare Struktur, eine Autorität irgendwie, der Mann liefert mir die Pizza, der sorgt dafür.
Ja, wir haben da allerdings auch weiter, damit keiner sagen kann, die Pizza war eine Minute zu spät.
Was haben wir da?
Jede Pizzaschachtel, eine Uhr, die auf die Nanosekunde genau anzeigt, wann sie da war, damit nicht nachher jemand sagt, hey, die Pizza war erst nach 31 Minuten da.
Also es klingt mir nach wie vor nach Misstrauen.
Ja, ist ja auch egal.
Ich meine, ich wollte jetzt ja gar nicht die grundsätzliche Frage anscheiden. Also wir haben jetzt jedenfalls Gesetze, wir haben Verträge, wir bewerfen uns aus irgendeinem Grund mit Papier und wir glauben, dass unsere Zivilisation nur, indem wir uns verbindliche Papiere zu werfen, funktioniert. Ob das richtig ist oder nicht, das sei dahingestellt. Dazu machen wir nächstes Mal eine Sendung. Jetzt nehmen wir das mal als gegeben an.
Na ja, da möchte ich doch noch einhaken und sagen, es geht zumindest nicht ums Verträge machen, sondern es geht darum, wenn du dich nachher verzankt hast, das zu beweisen. Also wenn du was kaufst und die Sache ist fein und so, dann willst du ja nie wieder was vom Faktor verbreiten.
Ja, aber das ist doch in dem Moment ein sogenannter Vertrag. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt zu Bruthojer sage, er gibt mir eine Pizza, so, und ich unterschreibe das, sei es jetzt hier auf dem Dat Papier oder eben mit meiner digitalen Signatur, dann habe ich mit ihm einen Vertrag geschlossen. Ich bekomme von ihm Pizza, er bekommt von mir Geld. Das ist der übliche Deal. So, jetzt können wir natürlich sagen, wir machen irgendwie Werksvertrag und BGB und bla, aber nehmen wir an, wir machen es schriftlich so. Und jetzt liefert er mir die Pizza und ich sag, ich Pizza bestellt, du bala bala oder was so. Und jetzt hat er die Pizza, die dampft irgendwie. Er hat aber schon gegessen und er will sein Geld und ich sage, habe ich nicht bestellt. Und dann kann er das Teil rauslernen und sagen, du hast bestellt und dann zerrt er mich von Kadi und dann muss ich nicht nur die Pizza bestellen, sondern auch noch irgendwelche blöden Juristen. Und wenn ich Pech habe, dann auch noch irgendwie keine Ahnung was.
Ja, sag ich ja, also erst mal um ganz klarzustellen, es geht nicht um den Pizza-Kauf, der klappt auch so gut, sondern erst wenn ihr euch verzankt habt, um es vor Gericht zu beweisen.
Na ja gut, aber dahinter steht ja dann doch das Misstrauen. Dahinter steht das Misstrauen des Pizza-Hintlers. Er könnte diesen telefonischen oder sonstigen, eben nicht vertraglichen Pizza-Bestellungen nicht trauen. Weil er könnte ja beschissen werden. Er könnte lauter Leute Pizza bestellen und die wird da dann nicht los, hat kein Geld, ist pleite, hat lauter Pizzen um sich rumliegen. Die riechen zwar gut, aber davon kann er seine Miete nicht bezahlen. So, und das heißt doch, dass das Misstrauen hier die treibende Kraft ist. Da können wir uns doch kurz drüber einig werden, das ist doch auch kein Verbrechen. Ich meine, es gibt halt Leute, die sind so und es gibt Leute, die sind so. Gut, also was der Gesetzgeber sich ausgedacht hat, ist doch, dass man sagen will, okay, ich will auch eben eine Pizza bestellen können, elektronisch. Und ich will als Händler die Sicherheit haben, dass die mir abgenommen wird oder zumindest, dass ich mein Geld einklagen kann. Ja, dass ich es beweisen kann.
Naja, nicht vielleicht eher, dass es überhaupt nicht in Frage gestellt wird.
Ganz genau, übrigens, wenn du die Pizza telefonisch bestellst, ist es auch ein Vertrag, dass wahrscheinlich das missverständlich ist.
Ja, aber du kannst schlechter nachweisen, dass der wirklich angerufen hat.
Ja, es geht nur um das Beweisen.
Also es ist nicht nur bei E-Commerce so, sondern auch bei allen Aspekten, die man in realen Leben hat. Du kommst schon wieder mit zur Abkürzung. Was soll denn E-Commerce sein? Das frag ich mich auch jeden Tag. Ich kenne lauter Leute, die so komische Firmen, das heißt halt irgendwie E-Commerce.
Das ist ein Aktien-Aktivierungskonzept oder so.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert so. Ich erzähle den Krawattenträgern, die vom Internet nichts verstehen, dass man mit dem Internet reich werden kann. Und ich nenne dieses E-Commerce und dann geben die mir Geld, das kann ich dann ausgeben, wegen E-Commerce.
Dafür brauchen wir digitale Signaturen.
Ja, wenn man Rundgast heißt und sich profilieren will und alle anderen machen E-Commerce und ich muss auch irgendwas machen, dann mache ich halt digitale Signaturen. So ungefähr kann man sich das vorstellen. Aber um jetzt noch mal ganz kurz vielleicht auch ein klein bisschen konkreter zu werden, also es gibt etwas, das heißt deutsches digitales, nee deutsches Signaturgesetz und es gibt dazu auch Verordnungen und Bestimmungen und allerlei Dinge und dahinter steht eben, dass die Idee, das Konzept, das Beweisbare von mir aus, digitale Unterschriften unter digitale elektronische Dokumente zu machen, die sich dann auch nicht verfälschen lassen können. So auch zum Beispiel einen Zeitstempel haben, damit jemand nachweisen kann, er hat wirklich viertel vor zwölf dieses Dokument, das er irgendwie ans Bericht schicken wollte, tatsächlich unterschrieben und hat das zum Metall-Stempel versehen lassen. Eventuell noch dazu. Und jetzt könnte man sagen, okay, die Politik hat sich was ausgedacht, das ist möglicherweise ganz toll. Wenn man allerdings jetzt fragt, gibt es denn so etwas? Gibt es denn Leute, die machen digitale Signaturen nach den Bestimmungen des deutschen Signaturgesetzes, dann lautet die Antwort wie? Nein. Das Problem ist, dass das Signaturgesetz und auch die dazu passende, obwohl da mische ich mich jetzt gerade wo ein, halt einfach noch keine Gesetzeskraft hat, dass die Bildung halt so ein bisschen als Ansteuern sorgt. Nein nein nein, das gibt es.
Wir machen jetzt mal doch kurz den juristischen Überblick zum Thema.
Dann machen wir lieber erstmal Musik.
Ja, das würde ich auch vorschlagen und den juristischen Überblick nach den Nachrichten, oder? Das wird glaube ich länger, ich kenne euch Brüder doch. Andy, was machst du da?
Entschuldigung, ich spiel hier ein bisschen rum.
Ich merke das.
Würdest du uns bitte unterlassen? Ich möchte auf den Hörer nicht zumuten, unsere juristischen Spitzfähigkeit nach außen zu tragen.
Warum spielst du hier ein Schirm? Dann sollst du über juristische Dinge reden. Ich sehe uns das nicht vor auf dem Kupferspass.
Demonstration. Rund 2000 Menschen haben am Abend in Brandenburg-Hafel gegen die geplanten Kürzungen bei den Kitas protestiert. Vertreter der Demonstranten übergaben Listen mit gesammelten Unterschriften. Zu den Protesten hatte die Gewerkschaft ÖTV aufgerufen. Sie sieht durch die Einsparungen den gesetzlichen Betreuungsanspruch in Kindertagesstätten und Arbeitsplätze bedroht. Fortschritt. Die Einrichtung von sogenannten Fixerstuben wird in Deutschland legalisiert. Der Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundesrat und Bundestag einigte sich am Abend auf einen leicht geänderten Gesetzentwurf. Morgen soll das Gesetz den Bundestag passieren. Vorhaben. Bundeskanzler Schröder will EDV-Experten aus dem Ausland nach Deutschland holen. Bei der Eröffnung der Computermesse Cebit am Abend in Hannover sagte Schröder, man werde den Fachkräften eine Aufenthaltserlaubnis nach dem Vorbild der US Green Card geben. Gleichzeitig forderte der Kanzler die Wirtschaft auf, arbeitslose deutsche Ingenieure für die Computerbranche umzuschulen. Ermittlungen der beabsichtigte Amoklauf der Schülerin in Münchenberg war von ihr in allen Einzelheiten geplant. Laut Staatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt Oder wollte die 16-Jährige mit Handgranaten und halbautomatischen Waffen Schüler und Lehrer ihres Gymnasiums töten. Ihr droht nun eine Anklage wegen geplanten Mordes. Fußball in einem Testländerspiel besiegte die niederländische Fußballauswahl am Abend in Amsterdam das deutsche Team mit 2 zu 1. Wetter. Heute Nacht kring bewölkt 0 bis minus 4 Grad am Tage, bewölkt unterregnerisch Temperaturen um 7 Grad.
Verkehr.
Schwerlasttransport. Verkehr. A19 Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Röbel und Rheig-Wittstock fährt ein Schwerlasttransport. Der kann nicht überholt werden.
Ach nicht?
Da kann man hinter hängen bleiben.
Don Halleckchen, Kurzinfo mit Gerald Kötter, eingereicht um 23.32. Vielen Dank.
Fritz präsentiert United Colors of Sound Systems. Eine ganz spezielle Empfehlung des Blackboard Jungle. Und natürlich von...
So, ich werde jetzt mal versuchen zu erklären, was das Problem mit der Beweiserei ist. Also, wenn ich von Andi einen Gebrauchtwagen kaufe, zum Beispiel, und der fährt dann total super, dann ist das ja alles kein Problem. Aber wenn ich nachher rausfinde, dass er keine Fensterhebe hat und irgendwie das Getriebe nicht so geht, wie es soll, dann will ich natürlich mein Geld zurück und jetzt sagt der Andi natürlich so, habe ich dir doch alles vorher erzählt. Wenn ich jetzt zum Richter laufe und ihm ein schriftliches Dokument, eine sogenannte Urkunde vorlege, die der Andere unterschrieben hat, wo drin steht irgendwie Fensterheber sind total gut und Auto läuft super, dann glaubt mir der Richter das augenblicklich. Das ist der sogenannte Urkundenbeweis. Das ist in Deutschland so, wenn man was auf Schwarz, auf Weiß geschrieben hat, dann glaubt ein Richter das auch sofort.
Und wenn ich sage, ich habe das nicht beschrieben?
Ja, dann Gutachter und riesen Aufwand, aber du musst das beweisen, dass das dann gefälscht ist.
Da muss ich irgendwie ein Schriftgutachter und wenig alles heranzerren und sagen, unschuld.
Also du hast erstmal schlechte Karten, wenn ich was Schriftliches habe. Wenn ich jetzt aber irgendwas anderes habe, und sei es, dass ich unser Gespräch aufgezeichnet habe, wie wir sagen, ich kaufe das Auto, dann kann der Richter selber entscheiden, wie überzeugend er das findet.
Also die freie Beweiswürdigung durch den Richter.
Und jetzt ist das Problem, dass wenn man dem Richter sagt, ja ich habe hier ein digital unterschriebenes Dokument, und wir Hacker wissen natürlich, das ist viel sicherer als eine Papierunterschrift. Aber wenn es ordentlich gemacht ist, aber der Richter weiß das nicht, da muss ich einen Gutachter kommen lassen, der tut einen Gegengutachter kommen, und bis unsere Gutachter dem Richter verklärt haben, was da abgegangen ist, haben wir irgendwie schon 15.000 Mark Gutachterkosten, und der Prozess ist drei Jahre her und sonst was. Und da haben sich die Leute oder der Gesetzgeber, wer auch immer, gedacht, machen wir ein Gesetz, damit der Richter auch so versteht, was eine digitale Signatur ist, und dann weiß er auch, was das ist.
Aber sollte man dem Richter nicht lieber eine Packung Bildung irgendwie zu werfen?
Wäre durchaus auch ein guter Ansatz, denn das Problem ist, dass dieses Signaturgesetz, das sagt halt, eine digitale Signatur im Sinne dieses Gesetzes ist Folgendes, das sagt aber an gar keiner Stelle, Richter, das hast du jetzt zu glauben, oder gar, was digital signiert ist, ist eine Urkunde und genauso gut wie auf Papier geschrieben, sondern das sagt einfach, eine digitale Signatur ist das hier. Deshalb ändert das erstmal gar nicht viel.
Aber deswegen sitzen wir jetzt hier, weil sich das gerade ändern soll, weil die EU gerade beschlossen hat, dass jetzt alle das ändern müssen.
Na, warte, Pluto, wenn du das Mikrofon nicht unter dein Kinn hältst, sondern vor deinen Mund, da kann man dich auch besser verstehen.
Also ganz kurz, es gibt diesen blöden deutschen Gesetzgeber wie auch immer, der hat jetzt gesagt, wir machen die digitale Signaturen. Und der hat dazu ja nicht nur ein Gesetz gemacht, sondern dann gibt es noch eine Verordnung. Und da stehen in der Verordnung so interessante Sätze drin, wie es muss 100% sichergestellt sein, dass das Dokument, das sich der normalsterblichen Bürger zum Beispiel an den Bildschirm holt, was heißt ich Kaufvertrag von Auto und Haus oder was auch immer, und dann mithilfe seiner Chipkarte zum Beispiel signiert, dass sozusagen das, was am Bildschirm angezeigt wird, auch 100%ig das ist, was die Chipkarte signiert. Und das sind halt fromme Wünsche, die natürlich mit einer Microsoft-Betriebssystem-Realität schon mal gar nicht zu tun haben. Und auch einer der Gründe sind, warum so genannter Nachbesserungsbedarf in den gesetzlichen Bestimmungen ja konstantiert wurde. Aber was jetzt passiert ist, ist nicht, dass die sich jetzt irgendwie was Tolles, Besseres ausgedacht haben, sondern jetzt haben wir das Ganze selber noch mal von der europäischen Ebene. Und da hat Herr Pluto möglicherweise eine etwas präzisere Bestandsaufnahme. Warum haben die das gemacht? Weil die das Deutsche nicht wollten oder weil die das war auch noch mal oder weil die, wo es in Deutschland schon keinen interessiert, dass das Ganze auch noch mal in Europa im Sinne der Mittelverschwendung durchführen wollten? Na, die Hoffnung ist wohl generell irgendwie auf allgemeines Geld sparen und...
Mal mal ein Mikro ein Stück höher, das ist ja furchtbar.
Na, also es wurde von der EU umgesetzt. Im Prinzip das, was wir als CG in Deutschland schon mal hatten, also als Signaturgesetz. Und zwar in zwei Teilen. Es gibt sozusagen die Strängen dem Gesetz Folgenden. Das ist so etwa das, was das CG war. Also die katholischen. Die katholischen und dann gibt es noch die evangelischen. Und die katholischen wollten irgendwie die anderen EU-Länder nicht. Also die Erzkatholischen quasi. Und von daher ist das jetzt wahlfrei, ob man das jetzt macht. Aber es gibt sozusagen eine abgeschwächte Version des Signaturgesetzes. Du sagst jetzt klar, der wahlfrei, aber mich hat doch auch vorher zum Glück keiner gezwungen. Das wäre noch schöner, dass ich mich jetzt in meinen E-Mails oder wo auch immer an das deutsche Signaturgesetz halte.
Also das wäre total absurd.
Aber was heißt denn wahlfrei? Die CA kann sich quasi entscheiden. Danke. Da habe ich auch noch ein englisches Wort für. Authentification Authority. Moment, jetzt fangen wir ja gerade an beim Chaos Computer Club auf einmal Autoritäten zu schaffen. Hör ich das richtig? Ja, Autoritäten sind auf jeden Fall klasse. Da muss man sich verbeugen und überhaupt Achtung haben. Aber im Prinzip geht es darum, man hat halt eine Stelle und die sagt halt irgendwie, okay dich kenn ich, weil von dir hab ich zum Beispiel den Personalausweis gesehen, irgendwie die lange Nase erkenne ich sofort wieder oder sonstiges. Und dann sagt, drückt sie ihren Stempel unter dein Zertifikat, also unter deinen elektronischen Ausweis. Also um rau zu sein. Ja, das kenn ich schon. Ich bin dann auf irgendwelchen wildfremden Veranstaltungen, dann geben mir Leute ihre Visitenkarte oder ihren PGP-Key oder so und dann halten sie mir ihren Personalausweis unter die Nase und dann soll ich das auf einmal glauben. Also dann soll ich so jemanden, der mir seinen Perse unter die Nase hat, den ich überhaupt nicht sehen will, soll ich jetzt auf einmal vertrauen? Hingegen jemand, den ich lange kenne, wo ich gar nicht weiß, ob der überhaupt einen Personalausweis hat, der ist dann auf einmal weniger wert, richtig? Ja, also es wird so für den offiziellen Gebrauch. Also ist das sinnvoll? Na, es wird benutzt für halt irgendwie diesen ganzen offiziellen Kram, dieses Anmelden, Auto, Blah, irgendwie...
Es ist zumindest objektiv, weil die Zertifizierung durch dein Vertrauen ist ja eine rein subjektive Zertifizierung.
Der Staat ist natürlich objektiv, das hab ich vergessen.
Das wollte ich auch gar nicht sagen.
Verwechselst du da Signieren mit Vertrauen? Du sagst nicht dem vertraue ich und alles was der sagt ist toll, sondern du sagst nur, ich glaube, dass er, der ist, der auf dem Personalausweis steht.
Da hast du natürlich recht. Ich kam natürlich deswegen jetzt, weil er brachte jetzt die CAs ins Spiel. Also um das vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zu erklären, es gibt halt, wenn man mit ganz vielen Menschen, zum Beispiel mit 80 Millionen Staatsbürgern versucht, digitale Signaturen einzuführen und möglicherweise hatten die die naive Hoffnung, genau das zu tun, dann stellt sich halt die Frage, wie kann ich überprüfen, an welchem Computer kann ich überprüfen, dass wenn er mir jetzt irgendwas schickt und sagt, ich will jetzt dein Auto kaufen und meine Signature ist so, dass er auch er ist. Wie kann ich jetzt verhindern, dass ich mein Auto jetzt los bin, ohne Geld zu kriegen, weil jemand die Signature gefälscht hat. Und dazu gibt es eben, das glaube ich ist das, was du sagen wolltest, ja auch immer, dazu gibt es eben unter anderem CAs, Zertifizierungsautoritäten nennt man das. Das heißt, seine Signatur wiederum ist signiert von einer Autorität und diese Autorität kann zum Beispiel der Staat sein oder kann hier der Nette Holger sein oder kann Radio Fritz sein oder kann wer auch immer sein. In dem Zusammenhang? Von dem weiß ich, dass er existiert, kann es überprüfen und der wiederum bestätigt, dass dieser Pluto existiert. Also im Prinzip läuft es darauf hinaus, du glaubst dem Staat, dass er, sagen wir mal, in der Verwaltung…
Na ja, das ist schon ziemlich schlau gemacht. Also diese Stelle, die sagt, dass die Zertifizierungsautoritäten existieren, das ist ja das ehemalige Bundespostministerium und wir HAKA haben ja oft schon Kontakt mit dem gehabt und irgendwie die meisten von uns glauben, dass das existiert. Zum Teil standen die Jungs ja auch schon vor der Tür und haben Modems eingesammelt und so gesehen, ist das schon ziemlich real, dass die da sind?
Die Frage ist halt, ist es auch real, dass man ihnen glauben kann? Also was wir hier haben ist halt eine hierarchische...
Reinländer? Bist du ein Reinländer?
Nee, aber ich trinke trotzdem Kölsch.
Ich habe noch ein kleines Problem.
Das ist halt von so Menschen wie Helmut Kohl irgendwie begründet wurden und durchsetzt. Waren von Personal, dass diesen Autoritäten ergeben war und ihnen vertraut hat. Und jetzt soll ich also dem Staatswesen wieder vertrauen, oder wie? Na, was heißt du dem Staatswesen vertrauen? Nicht unbedingt, dass es gut mit deinen Steuergeldern umgeht oder dass es immer nett zu allen ist oder sonstiges, aber in dem Fall hat halt der Staat sozusagen die Autorität zu sagen, irgendwie dich kenne ich, von dir habe ich irgendwie, dich habe ich beobachtet seit deiner Geburt über dein Geburtszertifikat, deinen Geburtsschein, bis hin irgendwie, bis du dann irgendwie dein Abi gemacht hast, da habe ich auch ein Zertifikat, das ist von einem Menschen ausgestrahlt worden, dem ich das glaube, weil ich habe ihn verbeamtet, nämlich dem Direktor der Schule, an dem du dein Abi gemacht hast, sprich du hast halt eine Folge vom Staat, beglaube ich, den Zertifikaten, mit denen du dich zum Beispiel gegenüber deinem Arbeitgeber ausweist, dass du ein Abi gemacht hast, dass du irgendwie die Uni besucht hast, ob man das jetzt glauben will oder ob es Dass es auch Möglichkeiten gibt darum rumzukommen, das ist noch eine andere Sache. Erstens, wie funktioniert das und zweitens finden wir das sinnvoll.
Also noch mal kurz dazu, die Sache ist im Prinzip, musst du dem Staat da vertrauen, weil wenn du, Moment, wenn du einen Vertrag einklagen willst, also wenn du jetzt irgendwie von mir willst, dass die 1000 Mark für dein Auto bezahlt, dann laufst du ja auch zum Staat holend hin und sagst irgendwie, Richter, verklage mal.
Dann ruf ich meine Kumpels an und dann gibt das auf die...
Ja, dem brauchst du aber auch zu inspirieren, einen Vertrag zu vorzulegen.
Also ich meine, ich stehe da ja eher auf dem Prinzip der Berliner Flohmal-Kultur, das zusammengefasst lautet irgendwie, fickst du meine Mutter, fick ich deine Mutter. Also es ist ganz einfach.
Er hat das F-Wort gesagt.
Entschuldigung, war man das bei diesen Radiosendern?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Also wir hatten irgendwie vorletzte Radiosendern und war Martin mit dabei und er hat dann nach Herzenslust einen Dialog entsponnen, wo wir uns alle gewundert haben, was hat das jetzt mit dem Thema zu tun. Und danach, es war uns keinen aufgefallen, sagte er, hey, ich hab dicke Titten im Radio gesagt.
Du jetzt auch.
Er hat ihn nur zitiert, also das ist ein bisschen was anderes, das ist Weiswissenschaft. Aber kommen wir noch mal zurück. Also Signaturen, Zertifizierungsautoritäten, ich kann dem Staat glauben oder auch nicht. Die Frage ist, baue ich auf dem Misstrauens, Vertrauens, wie auch immer Konzept des Staates meine Signaturen auf oder nicht? Da gibt es jetzt halt das andere Konzept. Jetzt hatten wir das hier Reichliche, hier Rass. Das sozusagen Katholische. Das Katholische, sprich es gibt einen Papst, der hat immer recht, das ist in dem Fall der Staat, und der hat halt seine Jünger und die laufen rum und die haben auch immer recht, weil die glauben ihrem Papi und der hat halt immer recht. Dann gibt es noch das andere, sprich das Pro-Mark-Prinzip, so das Internet- und Blümchenwiese-Prinzip, sprich irgendwie man kennt sich und man fraut sich so ein bisschen, man weiß so ein bisschen wer der ist. Ach ja, das ist der Doobie, den habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesehen irgendwie. Das heißt, ich weiß wer er ist und er weiß vielleicht auch wer Andi ist, vielleicht weiß er nicht wer selber ist, aber vielleicht kennt er den auch noch. Und das ist dann so eine Art von Vertrauen Web of Trust. Das heißt, ich habe keine Hierarchie, sondern ich habe eher eine Verletzung.
Der hat das größte Stuhl gefangen. Was ist da passiert? Ich mach gerade mal krass und dann befreien wir das Pluto.
Okay, also wir waren bei den katholischen Autoritäten und jetzt den verteilten Autoritäten, also dem Web of Trust, und dann gibt es da aber noch was? Na, viel, also neben diesen beiden Prinzipien kommt da eigentlich nicht mehr viel. Also ich meine, es gab zwei Unterschiede vielleicht ganz kurz, weil ich sie wichtig finde, in der deutschen... Orthodox Katholisch und Glocken Katholisch. Genau, auch bei den Katholischen gab es sozusagen zwei Konzepte, das eine war das deutsche Konzept, die haben gesagt, der Gesetzgeber definiert ganz genau, wie diese Autoritäten funktionieren müssen. Also da wurde denen mehr oder weniger festgeschrieben, wie dick die Mauern sein müssen und wie viele Bretter die Angestellten vorm Kopf haben müssen und alles. Also bis ins feinste Detail geringer.
700 Seiten oder so?
Was allerdings nicht geregelt war, war die Tatsache, das nähen wir mal an. Den unwahrscheinlichen Fall der Gesetzgeber hat irgendwas übersehen. Und ich hole mir so eine digitale Signatur, die gibt's in einem Notar, legt meinen Versuch vor, geb irgendwie Geld, hab so ein Ding. Und jetzt vermählt sich jemand mit meiner digitalen Signatur, mit irgendeiner Frau, die ich einfach mal nicht riechen kann, nicht kenne, keine Ahnung, wie es geschehen ist. Und jetzt geh ich zum Gesetz, zum Richter hin und sag, also sorry, die Braut, die kenn ich nicht, die kann's irgendwie nicht sein, will ich umtauschen so. Und dann sagt er, ja, aber digital signiert. Also muss ja richtig sein. Viel Spaß, so. Dann hab ich die Scheiße. Und ganz kurz, im deutschen Gesetz kann man glaube ich sagen, da war dieser Fall irgendwie nicht so richtig geregelt. Im europäischen jetzt haben die einfach gesagt, die Zertifizierungs-Strukturen, die können aussehen, wie sie wollen. Das heißt, sie können so dicke Wände haben oder so dünne, ist total egal, aber sie haften für den Fall, und zwar richtig auf Markt und Pfennig, dass digitale Signaturen auf irgendeine Art und Weise verpelst werden können. Aber sie setzen beide halt irgendwie an der Mitte an. Also sprich die Leute, die die Unterschriften leisten, also sprich die Notarien in diesem Spiel, die das Ganze zertifizieren und bestätigen, die werden halt überprüft, werden irgendwo bestätigt. Aber was du eben da schon sagtest mit dem Signature-Gesetz, was ist da das Problem, dass halt die Leute, die da draußen das benutzen, eventuell mit Rechnern arbeiten, wo zum Beispiel ein Irrteil nicht geschützt ist. Weil so ein signiertes Zert ist halt irgendwo ein Datei, und wenn man sich das vorstellt, so eine Datei, die kann man hin und her melden, die kann man auf eine Karte tun, die kann man aber auch auf seinem PC abspeichern. Und wenn der PC zufälligerweise irgendwie in die Hände von anderen Leuten fällt, dann kann es halt passieren, dass quasi jemand meinen Personalausweis hat. Und dieser Personalausweis hat kein Foto von mir, sondern er hat nur eine Zahlenkombination sowie die PIN von meiner EC-Karte. Und damit bestätige ich, dass dieser Personalausweis mir gehört. Und wenn jemand auch noch die PIN kennt, dann bedeutet das, dass er meinen Personalausweis hat und völlig legitim behaupten kann, er ist ich. Aber dann klingt das Ganze doch so wie ein Konzept, von dem ich unter dem Strich sagen würde, will ich nicht haben, oder?
Da das lustig ist, dass der Gesetzgeber das auch weiß. Bevor er das Gesetz gemacht hat, hat er zwei Studien in Auftrag gegeben, die mal geguckt haben, wie kann das denn so ungefähr klappen, vertrauenswürdiger elektronischer Rechtsverkehr. Und die Studien haben gesagt, das geht dauernd schief. Die Leute schreiben ihre PIN auf die Karte, der Chef gibt seine Karte samt PIN der Sekretärin. Irgendwie Leute verändern die Software.
Es war mein Unterschriftautomat.
Die Software zeigt andere Sachen an, als man unterschreibt. Oder die Software manipuliert das hier immer. Sagt, ja, Signatur ist okay. Und diese Gutachten sind an den Gesetzgeber gegangen, an die Leute, die Gesetze gemacht haben. Die wussten das alles, dass das dauernd schief läuft. Und von den EC-Karten weiß man ja, dass wirklich Leute sich nicht mal eine vierstellige PIN merken können.
Kirschweige denn so aufbewahren, dass sie keiner sieht? Oder wie man bei den PINs gemerkt hat, ist da auch irgendwo ein Gedanke mit Technik? Darfst du nochmal hinterher reden, warum verschwenden wir dann unsere Lebenszeit mit Konzepten, von denen wir offenbar wissen, dass wir sie nicht haben wollen? Also wir haben ja auch eine Alternative.
Was heißt haben wollen?
Wir benötigen sie nicht.
Wir benötigen sie eigentlich.
Nein, wir benötigen sie nicht. Ja, meine ich ja. Naja, es gibt halt eine Menge Dinge, wo du, was weiß ich, z.B. Zertifizierung deines Wissensstandes durchs Abi tue. Da fragt man sich irgendwie, will man das wirklich? Manche machen es trotzdem, aber es läuft halt darauf hinaus, in manchen Sachen kommt man irgendwie echt schlecht rum. Also im Abi kommt man vielleicht noch rum, aber z.B. sich irgendwo anzumelden zu müssen und dafür auch irgendwie ein Personaldokument dann außerhändlich zu kriegen, wo drin steht, dass du da gemeldet bist. Da kommst du in einem Staat relativ schlecht rum, weil er halt als einen seiner Dienste gegenüber seinen Bürgern sieht, dass er den Überblick hat, wer wo wohnt und dass er irgendwie jedem auf die Finger klopfen kann, falls er jemand anderen irgendwie den Arsch treibt.
Also Arsch treten, kannst du ruhig sagen, Arsch treten.
Achso, das ist erlaubt.
Du kannst auch Ficken sagen, glaube ich, ist so schlimm nicht.
Wir können jetzt mal ganz kurz, vielleicht kommen wir auch noch mal zu konstruktiven Konzepten. Okay, also jetzt haben wir ganz detailliert erläutert, was wir nicht wollen.
Jetzt sagen wir mal, warum denn gesagt wird, dass man es braucht. Also irgendwie das Killer-Argument, was momentan jeder Politiker rund um die Uhr sagt, wir wollen E-Commerce fadern. Und das ist halt ohne digitale Signatur.
Nicht schon wieder, Andy. Ich mach deinen Mikro aus.
Okay, dann sag ich jetzt das Wort E-Commerce.
Das darf man im Radio nicht sagen.
Okay, also wegen E-Commerce, alles klar. Ja, die Leute gehen halt davon aus, dass irgendwie Einsparungspotenziale besteht. Das ist so das Lieblingswort seit einem halben Jahr. Also bis vor einem halben Jahr haben alle immer... Freistellung von Arbeitskräften? Ja, Einsparungspotenziale werden in Zusammenhang mit IT und Computern immer darauf hinaus, dass gewisse Leute sich danach nicht überflüssig, aber eingespart fühlen dürfen. Also im Sinne von sie persönlich nicht, aber ihre Position halt. Und das, was sie davor haben, ist halt nicht nur Förderung des Handels im Internet und global und weltweit, sondern es geht halt auch zum Beispiel um Schriftverkehr. Also es gibt immer noch Leute, die das Wort Papierloses Büro in den Mund nehmen können, ohne dabei ganz heftigen Lachen auszurechnen.
Nein, wenn ich mir angucke, was hier, wo überall Rechner stehen und ein Netzwerk läuft, das sogar noch halbwegs stabil ist, an Papier abfällt.
Also die Druckindustrie hat, seitdem das Wort gegründet wurde, irgendwie einen richtig guten Boomer erfahren, weil danach wussten die Leute endlich, was sie wirklich haben wollen. Ein bisschen Schriftpapier, mit dem man irgendwie eine Fliege tot schmeißen kann.
Genau und das Totschlag-Argument da ist, ich kann auf dem Bildschirm einfach nicht Korrektur lesen.
Du, wie du zuttelst da mit irgendeinem Papier rum, willst du uns irgendwie etwas sagen?
Ja, ich möchte euch so gerne was sagen. Also der Gesetzgeber hat ja vor drei Jahren die Signaturgesetz gemacht.
Der alte damals noch, ja?
Genau und als er es gemacht hat, hat er gesagt, der Neue soll sich mal damit beschäftigen. Nämlich in zwei Jahren will ich einen Bericht darüber sehen, ob das gut gelaufen ist.
Aber der zuckt doch schon nicht mal mehr.
Ja, er hat ja vor drei Jahren gesagt, also er dachte, dass er noch Gesetzgeber wär. Und da stehen dann solche Sachen wie das Signaturgesetz, bildet die Voraussetzung für einen sicheren elektronischen Rechts- und Geschäftsverkehr. Also das heißt, ohne können wir gar nicht Rechts- und Geschäftsverkehr elektronisch haben.
Ja, aber ich meine, Kanter hat es auch ganz anders angesagt.
Der hat auch gesagt, er würde was gegen organisierte Kriminalität und Geldwäsche unternehmen wollen.
Und digitale Signaturen werden nach dem Signaturgesetz unter anderem in folgenden Bereichen bereits erfolgreich angewandt, oder es zeichnet sich eine Anwendung ab? Sozialversicherungen, Gesundheitswesen, Steuerdaten, elektronische Ausschreibung öffentlicher Aufträge und elektronische Angebotsabnahme, elektronische Dokumentation, Vertrieb von Software, Verkehr zwischen Bürgern, Unternehmen und öffentlicher Verwaltung, elektronisches Mahnverfahren, Zahlungsverkehr in Klammern Online-Banking und Online-Dienste. Das heißt also eigentlich sind wir praktisch nur von digitalen Signaturen umgeben, wenn man sich das hier so durchliest.
Ohne, dass ich jetzt gleich auf das F-Wort zurückkommen wollte, aber was für ein Verkehr zwischen Bürgern ist denn da gemeint? Naja, wie man das ohne Latex sicherkriegt.
Ich, ich dir nicht traue, wenn du mir deinen Benz verkaufst, weil ich der Meinung bin, dass da eventuell die Fenster eben nicht funktionieren.
Ja, dann musst du ausprobieren, bevor du Auto kaufst.
Scheißen Dreck Mercedes.
Ja, also irgendwie einmal Behördentram, das sind ja die meisten Punkte, Sozialversicherung, Steuer und sowas. Zum anderen halt untereinander Verträge machen. Darum ging's ihm.
Gut. Was ja auch irgendwo ein Ansatz ist, weil draußen gibt es tausende von kleinen Verträgen, die geschlossen werden, die auch bewiesen werden müssen. Und da ist dann halt Einspar und Möglichkeiten, dass die geteilt werden. Aber bewerfen sich die Leute denn da im Kleinen immer mit zu vielen Papieren?
Also die meisten Verträge mach ich doch eh ohne Papier. Ich mach mal kein schriftliches Dokument, wenn ich Brötchen kaufe.
Ich meine, so weit kommt das noch. Mit der Chipkarte kannst du dann auf einmal dieses dokumentierte Misstrauen in einer Perfektion betreiben. Aber was zum Beispiel ein Beispiel ist, wenn du ein Betriebssystem hast und du möchtest das jetzt updaten, dann schließt du zum Beispiel einen in dem Fall kostenfreien Vertrag mit dem Hersteller des Betriebssystems ab, dass er dir auf Knopfdruck oder auf die Eingabe eines Befehls auf die Kommandozeile einen Teil zur Verfügung stellt, der dein Betriebssystem noch schöner, noch schneller und noch freudiger macht. Und dieser Teil des Betriebssystems wird dir auf den Rechner geliefert und der Hersteller authentifiziert diesen Teil des Betriebssystems durch ein Zertifikat, das er selber hat. Und mit dem du, wenn du das anerkennst und glaubst, dann halt sicher davon ausgehen kannst, dass dieser Teil, der dir jetzt geliefert wird, tatsächlich von diesem Hersteller kommt. Aber die Frage ist, will ich das? Das kommt mir so vor, als würde ich eine Wohnung mieten irgendwie und der Vermieter sagt mir, hey, alle zwei Jahre kriegst du neue Möbel, deswegen brauch ich einen Wohnungsschlüssel. Vielleicht will ich das ja gar nicht. Also in dem Fall ist es echt praktisch, wenn ich jetzt mehr RPM installiere und ich weiß halt, wo der Maintainer... Also Teile von Betriebssystemen, die nicht mit W anfangen, sagen wir mal. Man könnte das auch User Ports für die andere...
Ich wollte dich nur ein bisschen stressen, weil du dauernd Abkürzungen benutzt hast.
Ja, es gibt ja für fast jedes Betriebssystem Schematare, mit denen es möglich ist, das Ding abzugraten. Bei der Gelegenheit ist dieses Upgrade, das da gefahren wird, also dieser zusätzliche Teil für das Betriebssystem, unterschrieben. Je nach Art des Betriebssystems ist das eine zentrale Stelle, die irgendwo in den USA sitzt, oder ein sogenannter Maintainer, also jemand, der dafür verantwortlich ist, dass dieses Paket für dein Betriebssystem immer alles enthält, was es enthalten soll. Und dass es irgendwie auch nicht ein truanisches Pferd zum Beispiel enthält. Das heißt, ich hole mir von A, also von irgendeinem Rechner, der irgendwo steht, hole ich mir das Paket. Und von dem Typen, der sich um das Paket kümmert, hole ich mir seinen Key. Dann gucke ich mir an, ob das Paket vollständig, nicht verändert ist. Und erst dann spiele ich es ein.
Könnte ich aber auch machen, indem ich in den Laden gehe, mir eine CD hole, die original verpackt ist.
Also im Grunde ist es eine Originalverpackung.
Also eine sogenannte Originalverpackung.
Also eine wunderbare Diskussion, die ihr habt. Aber dafür braucht man doch nicht das Signaturgesetz. Weil irgendwie, wenn ich mal das erste Mal mein Betriebssystem installiere...
Entschuldigung, wie waren wir nicht schon so weit, dass wir es eigentlich ohnehin nicht brauchen?
Ach, ich dachte nicht. Ich wollte noch darauf kommen, dass ich ganz gerne doch um eins vor Mitternacht meine Steuererklärung e-mailen möchte. Ich glaube, dafür braucht das Finanzamt schon möchte, dass die von mir es bestätigt haben. Und dafür ist das Signaturgesetz ganz praktisch, finde ich.
Oder wenn du Anwalt bist, dann kannst du eine Tagesschrift irgendwie schnell wählen. Die wollen dann lieber gleich in dein Computer gucken und deine Finanzamtsdaten heraus holen.
Ja, das kann ja aber auch ohne Signaturgesetz, das ist das Problem.
Das ist davon relativ unabhängig. Ich glaube, wir reden jetzt gleich nochmal auch über Anwendungen und alternative Strukturen, die wir ja auch noch haben. Ja. Dann können wir nochmal ein bisschen Musik hören und unsere Gedanken produzieren. Wir haben uns jetzt gerade überlegt, dass wir zur Steigerung der Interaktivität jetzt mal die ganz blöde Frage an euch stellen, ob euch das mit den digitalen Signaturen irgendwie sinnvoll vorkommt. Also ob es irgendeine Anwendung gibt, die sei es jetzt der katholische Gesetzgeber, der evangelische oder der vernetzte Gesetzgeber, der euch sozusagen tatsächlich mit digitalen Signaturen und der Anerkennung entgegenkommen würde. Keine Steuererklärung, irgendwie Nahrungsmittelversorgung, dokumentiertes Misstrauen gegenüber Lebensabschnittspartnern oder Ihnen.
Oder kaufen von Autos ohne Fensterheber.
Oder das.
Also Andi will es nicht brauchen wollen. Wer weiß, ob ihr es brauchen wollt.
Ich gerade noch nicht, aber wer weiß. Vielleicht kommt noch das gute Argument. Was?
Was runterziehen? Dich? Ach so. Das hat doch einfach so einen fürchterlichen Husten. Da gibt es eine Reusbandtaste, da steht Reusband drauf, da drückst du drauf, dann kannst du dich reusbanden. Die reusband sich dann für dich.
Wollten wir nicht nochmal die Musik hochreusbanden?
Also ruft uns mal an. Hat es da dann diese Rufnummer?
Die Hotspotline ist geschaltet.
031 für Potsdam.
70 97 1 1 0.
Wir würden gerne wissen, ob ihr euch vorstellen könnt, was denn so wichtig sein könnte, dass es digital signiert werden müsste. Ich lass es nochmal sein.
Die Hotspotline ist geschaltet.
Chaosradio, die 47. Ausgabe.
Da war noch dieser Jingle übrigens, den du da irgendwo...
Das war doch mal ein Jingle. Und wir haben auch einen Anrufer. Ich versuch mal hier mein Glück, ja. Ist der signiert? Ich weiß nicht. Mike, bist du signiert? Ja schade, das war also unser Anrufer. Ja, Mike war jetzt nicht dran, den hat's rausgehauen. Ich sag nochmal die Nummer an.
Die Spritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Ihr braucht wirklich keine Angst zu haben. Wir wollen von euch wissen, ob ihr euch vorstellen könnt, was irgendetwas signiert sein müsste. Also was würdet ihr gerne signiert haben wollen? Würdest du irgendwas gerne signiert haben wollen, Andi?
Ja, also die Frage ist, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Dokumente ohne Handy übers Internet schicke, irgendwie, klar, ich signiere auch mitunter Sachen. Da ist nämlich mein PGP-Scheiß, mein Key ist auf einem Servern, da hab ich eigentlich kein Problem mit. Allerdings hätte ich doch echte Hemmschwellen, eine digitale Signatur zu haben, mit der unter Umständen in meinem Namen Dinge geschehen können, deren Konsequenzen mich richtig Geld kosten. Also so viel vertraue ich der Technik einfach nicht, weil ich eben wees, das sind alles nur Nullen und Einsen und das ist alles echt eine relative Angelegenheit und die Betriebssysteme sind einfach nicht so toll und die Datenwege da zwischen eh nicht. Also da glaub ich einfach nicht wirklich dran.
Fragen wir mal Lars, woran der glaubt.
Hallo Lars. Naja, also ich könnte mir manchmal vorstellen, wenn man so staatliche Sachen oder sowas erledigt, wie zum Beispiel, wie er schon vorgeschlagen hat, mit dem Finanzamt und so. Weil da sind ja immer Unterschriften nötig und wenn man designiert, was vom Staat anerkannt ist, dann könnte man auch Staatsgeschäfte, so Briefverkehr oder sowas, gemäßig machen.
Das wäre sicherlich eine Entlastung.
Ja zum Beispiel.
Das wär ja schon schön, wenn ich, also ich meine, ich komme meiner Meldepflichter beispielsweise nach, wenn ich das per E-Mail machen könnte. Das wäre schon gar nicht schlecht.
Du meinst immer deine aktuelle IP-Adresse mailen und dann bist du deiner Meldepflicht nachgefunden.
Ja okay, ich meine, dann sagen wir, für die staatliche Schnittstelle ist eine Sache die Frage, kann ich dann mal Frage an die anwesenden Juristen, kann ich dann sagen für das Meldamt und fürs Finanzamtgedöns irgendwie okay, aber nicht unbedingt, dass man in meinem Namen gleich Häuser und Autos kaufen kann? Könnte ich das ausschließen, könnte ich sagen, also für die und die Anwendung okay, aber nicht für alles?
Als Gesetzgeber natürlich auf jeden Fall.
Nee, ich meine, ist das vorgesehen? Das ist jetzt eher eine Frage an die Technik.
Genau.
Im Himmelswein hat einer noch mal an die Technik gestellt.
Den nächsten Hörer, ja.
Guten Morgen.
Ja, folgendes, ich habe in letzter Zeit unheimlich viel Papierkram gehabt. Und da sitzt man dann den ganzen Tag oder die ganze Nacht am Computer, empfängt dort seine Fakte, verarbeitet seinen ganzen Krempel, schreibt das alles, tippt das alles. Und am Ende endet der ganze Prozess dann damit, dass man das Zeug auf den Drucker schickt, eintütet und dann vom Briefkasten jockelt und das Zeug dann abschicken muss. Und das wäre zum Beispiel eine Sache, wo ich mir das sehr gut vorstellen könnte, mit einer Signatur, das dann wegzuschicken. Oder wenn ich jetzt mal ein anderes Beispiel, was mich richtig geärgert hat, also ich bin aber bei so einer Aussicherung...
Ist das Behördenkorrespondenz oder was? Was ist das für Zeug? Ist das so Behördenkorrespondenz, was du meinst?
Ja, so Versicherung und Finanzkram und sich hier sparen und alles so ein Zeug.
Also schon auch irgendwie Verträge mit Firmen und so, wo es auch um Geld geht.
Ja, klar, etwas Bedeutungsvolleres, schön. Ja, oder wenn ich jetzt ein anderes Beispiel, Auto, was kaputt, Glasschaden oder Wildschaden oder Westergeier und ich komme dann zur Werkstatt, der macht mir das, dann drückt er mir da auf irgendein Gerät oder was, seine Rechnung und seine digitale Signatur und ich könnte das zur Versicherung schicken. Wäre zum Beispiel auch eine feine Sache. Spart mir auch wieder die ganze Arbeit, die ganzen Krampel da wieder zusammenzuschreiben, noch Briefe anschreiben dazu, alles fertig machen, dann wieder eintüten, zur Briefkasten, Post subventionieren wieder und alles solche Sachen.
Oder wir fälschen es in deinem Namen, kassieren Geld und du wirst in deiner Prämie hochgestuft.
Hättest du da keine Befürchtung oder würdest du das Risiko sozusagen auf den nehmen?
Also wenn das funktioniert, könnte ich mir das eben sehr gut vorstellen.
Und wenn das so seine Aussetzer hat, so wie die Computer im Internet waren?
Wenn das Aussetzer hat, dann sehe ich ziemlich dämlich aus. So wie letztens wieder, wo ich zum Online-Wenden verreute und die Deutsche Bank, die haben da irgendwie zur Zeit große Probleme, wenn man da am Tag versucht reinzukommen. Dann hat man ja das plastische Problem, da dann wieder ausdrucken, eintüten, hinlaufen oder hinschicken.
Also du meinst, solange man es zurückschalten kann, ist okay?
Okay Andreas, schalten wir zurück. Jörg, nabend Jörg, nee morgen Jörg.
Meine Signature ist meine erste Nummer, egal ob Handy-Nummer oder Festnetz-Nummer. Ich hab auch ein bisschen von Computern Ahnung, aber ich hab mein Siemens Expert, Independence 2, MNX erstmal meinem jungen Freund zur Verfügung gestellt, denn da ist zu viel schief gelaufen. Und jetzt ruf ich über das Handy an, obwohl ich genau weiß, dass das Teil auch eine Signatur für bestimmte Stellen ist, vor allem statische Stellen, die jeder kennt. Meine Meinung ist extrem, und ich oft genug aufgelaufen bin und darunter auch Erfahrungen so wie ich musste.
Deine Signatur ist deine Telefonnummer, sagst du? Genau. Kann ich eine Telefonnummer fälschen? Also kann ich mein ESDN-Telefon sagen, es soll dir eine andere Nummer anzeigen, als ich eigentlich habe?
Ja, es geht schon. Technisch ist das möglich. Es gibt halt bei ESDN-Anschlüssen, das wird ja auch als Sicherheitsfeature gehandelt. Und es gibt die eine Nummer, die bei dir im Display angezeigt wird, die in der Tat kann man verfälschen, wenn man einen Anlagenanschluss hat, der dieses Feature bietet, dass man sozusagen rufen kann von Nebenstellen oder sowas einblenden kann. Das ist ursprünglich ein Feature für Firmen, die zum Beispiel eine 0130er Nummer zum Zurückrufen haben. Und wenn die vom Callcenter anrufen wollen, die das in deinem Display die Nummer steht, und das kann man dann sozusagen ausnutzen. Also insofern, das ist kein wirkliches Sicherheitsfeature. Aber es gibt solche Methoden, wo man dann sagt, der Anschluss ist schon irgendwie ein Indikator dafür, wer da dranhängt. Die Frage ist auch da, aber natürlich nehmen wir mal an, dein Mobiltelefon klaue ich dir jetzt, lieber Anrufer, was auch immer. Und jetzt habe ich sozusagen damit deine Identität. Und jetzt geht's los. Jetzt bestelle ich mir einfach mal nicht eine Tüte Eis, sondern eine Eisdiele. Das ist aber nicht nur, dass irgendwie da die Identität geklaut werden kann, sondern der Punkt ist auch insofern interessant, das heißt, sobald ich solche Sachen mache, und zum Beispiel nicht nur alles das, was ich unterschreiben möchte, sondern einfach alles unterschrieben, was von mir rausgeht, einfach so per Default, weil es halt zum Beispiel Gesetz ist oder so, wie zum Beispiel bei deinem Handy, wo halt dein Netzbetreiber immer weiß, wo dein Handy ist und das auf 10 Meter peilen kann, dann hast du halt auch eine extreme Aufgabe von Anonymität.
Er kann es ja. Ich bin also Diplomgeologe. Ich hab mit Remotenting schon 1971 an der FU gearbeitet und entsprechende Satellitenfotos, Infrarot-Equivalentitäten, Falschfarbenaufnahmen ausgewertet und ich weiß, was 1971, geschweige 1980, und ich weiß, was jetzt möglich ist. Das ist nicht nur plus 10 Meter, das ist noch viel genauer möglich. Und macht euch keine Vorstellung, das ist alles möglich. Und da hat Toyota mit seiner Sermon schon gar nicht mal so unrecht. Das wisst ihr ja auch, Toyota, nichts ist unmöglich.
Allerdings, danke, ja.
Ja, ein paar Jahre auf 10 Meter.
Das Toyota Prinzip, ganz genau, mal gucken, was Hannes dazu sagt. Name Hannes.
Also ich wollte ja sagen, ihr redet ja schon die ganzen zwei Stunden darüber, wie man eigentlich Internet sicher machen kann, aber nicht darüber, warum man das eigentlich sicher machen will. Und so habe ich mir gedacht, ja, wem würde das eigentlich was bringen, wenn das Internet total sicher wär? Mir nicht. Und Antivirenfirmen zum Beispiel auch nicht. Und...
Dir würde es nichts bringen, wenn das Internet sicher wäre? Weil du kein Internet zu haben hast.
Wenn das jetzt total, total sicher wär. Also ich fände es auch ein bisschen langweilig.
Also sprich, du willst ein bisschen surfen, ein bisschen klicken, ein bisschen Spaß haben, und du gehst da draußen an E-Commerce und anderem läuft es dir eigentlich ziemlich wurscht. Also tut doch bitte, du kannst doch nicht immer wieder dieses E-Commerce sagen und es immer noch nicht definiert haben. Machen wir das nach dem Anruf?
Ich definiere das nächste in einem Monat und in drei Stunden.
Also ich nehme jetzt diesen Hörer mal in Schutz. Entschuldigung, wie hieß der noch schnell?
Das ist Hannes.
Hannes, hallo Hannes.
Ja hallo.
Also ich meine die Frage ist ja, du kannst doch ohne Signatur leben, hast du gesagt, ne?
Naja, also ich denke jetzt bei E-Commerce zum Beispiel, da ist es auch wichtig, dass ich da geschützt wäre, aber ich habe ja gehört, dass es auch nicht so sicher ist. Und da möchte ich zum Beispiel nicht. Und was eigentlich jetzt mein Gedanke war, das Internet wäre ja total, es wäre ja langweilig, wenn jetzt das Internet total hundertprozentig sicher wäre. Und dann ist ja die zum Beispiel, also jetzt als Beispiel das Klauen, also das ist bei der Schule, bei den Kindern, das war verboten und es macht auch trotzdem einen Reiz. Und wenn da jetzt ein paar Päckchen Kaugummis geklaut werden, das stört ja auch keinen. Wenn das jetzt total bewacht werden würde, dann wäre es echt langweilig. Und, also ich meine...
Wenn jetzt aber eine Million Leute, jeder zwei Päckchen Kaugummi klauen, dann fehlen zwei Millionen Päckchen Kaugummi. Und für denjenigen, der es kaufen will, wird das Kaugummi dann teurer. Also ich finde das schon eigentlich... Angenommen das Internet wäre hundertprozentig sicher, es würde mir schon wesentlich mehr Spaß machen.
Nein, das ist noch die Frage, weil irgendwie... Aber dann hätten wir auch die ganzen schicken MP3s nicht. Das ist ja schon klar. Das sind also verschiedene Dinge, die wir da so tun. Wenn man die so ganz buchstäblich nimmt, so naja...
MP was?
Okay, dann dreh doch mal das MP was hoch. Alles, danke für deinen Anruf. Also die Frage ist ja, wie wir sozusagen die Vorteile der Blümchenwiese mit den Anforderungen eines von mir aus auf auch kommerziellen Transaktionen... Also einfach an der gesellschaftlichen Infrastruktur, die nicht mehr nur Spielplatz irgendwie für ein paar Abenteuer ist, sondern die irgendwie zu so etwas wird wie Straßen, die... Ja, aber es scheint mir, als hätten wir in der Diskussion hier im Moment nur, wir reden immer nur entweder über die Blümchenwiese oder über die Autobahn mit irgendwie den platt gewalzten Kindern, die sich da aus Versehen von der Blümchenwiese draufgesetzt haben. Also es gibt ja vielleicht auch etwas dazwischen.
Den Feldweg.
Den Feldweg oder was auch immer. Oh, meine, es war ja... Wir haben ja auch selber, vielleicht sollten wir darauf auch mal kurz zu sprechen kommen, es gibt ja jetzt demnächst auch eine CCCCA. Wir haben uns also auch überlegt, wir spielen mal Autorität, aber wir machen das mit etwas anderen Regeln. Ja, also im Prinzip irgendwie so das dazwischen quasi irgendwie. Also wir zertifizieren auch. Das heißt, wir sorgen dafür... Ja, bestätigen. Wir bestätigen, dass jemand eine Datei geschickt hat, in der irgendwie etwas war, das man zertifizieren konnte. Das haben wir dann irgendwie getan und dann haben wir das zurückgeschickt. Wer das war und woher die kamen und wohin die gingen, ist uns leider nicht bekannt, weil wir sind halt alle ein bisschen schüsslich und wir haben das auch hingeschrieben, dass wir schüsslich sind. Also wir bestätigen alles. Wir haben uns einfach überlegt, wir bestätigen alles. Wir unterschreiben alles. Also wir sind eine sehr gutmütige Autorität. Wir glauben auch an das Gute im Menschen und deswegen bestätigen wir euch das, was auch immer. Ja, und was ihr dann damit anfängt, ist im Prinzip euer Bier und dass wir nicht dafür haften, ist irgendwie auch klar, weil wir wollen uns nicht anerkennen lassen und es steht auch in unserer Policy drin, dass wir das irgendwie nicht tun wollen und dass wir damit auch nichts bestätigen. Also von daher...
Das heißt, ich schicke jetzt irgendwas zu euch, also...
Ein Zertrequest.
Also ein Zertrequest und den schickt ihr zurück und sagt, ok, was immer du uns geschickt hast, da stand jetzt dein Pseudonym dritten. Holgi, immerhin ist jetzt schon mal sicher, dass dieser Schlüssel garantiert zu Holgi gehört und zu niemand anderem.
Also für dieses Zert hast du, wie in einem Ausweis, bestimmte Felder für Name, Vorname, Nachname und was es da noch so gibt, so Geburtsdatum und so. Klar, bei so einer digitalen Variante kann man im Prinzip auch Felder reinmachen, so viele wie man will. Und was wir halt bestätigen ist, während wir das unterschreiben, ist, dass wir etwas, was so aussieht, nicht zweimal getan haben. Also beim Unterschreiben passen wir auf, dass es Holgi irgendwie geboren haben, sowieso nicht zweimal gibt.
Das heißt, jemand, der sich dann auf dieses Zertifikat verlässt, muss euch vertrauen, also muss euch glauben, dass ihr die Wahrheit gesagt habt und falls ihr nicht die Wahrheit gesagt haben solltet, hat er aber Pech gehabt.
Na sag mal so, wenn du jetzt jemanden kennenlernst, und der sagt dir, schick mir doch mal, was irgendwie verschlüsselt, dann kannst du dieses Theater, das du von uns gekriegt hast, dafür benutzen. Und ihm nicht nur eine E-Mail damit schicken, also du zeigst ihm das halt, er glaubt dir das, du machst sozusagen Web of Trust innerhalb einer Hierarchie. Und dann schickst du ihm das nächste Mal etwas, was wieder mit dem gleichen Schlüssel verschlüsselt ist. Und weil es halt nur einen User davon gibt, glaubst du das halt auch wieder. Aber ich warne dich davor, da wirklich irgendwie so richtig Glauben reinzusetzen, weil so naja, eigentlich müsste man halt diesen Rechner irgendwie kein Päckchen Internet irgendwie ranlassen und der müsste irgendwie hinter Mauern stehen und dann mit der besten 20 Meter unter der Erde mit irgendwie so dicken Türen davor. Nur irgendwie verbeamtete und verbriefte irgendwie Leute dürfen daran. Und da wir irgendwie ein kleiner Verein sind und uns sowas einfach nicht leisten können, haben wir dafür halt unseren Webserver genommen. Und deswegen würde ich dir halt nicht raten, irgendwie da Staatsgeschäfte drüber abzuwickeln. Aber wenn du damit so ein bisschen verschlüsselt mailen willst und keinen Stress damit haben willst, oder wenn du damit zum Beispiel eine Website betreiben möchtest, dass die Leute über verschlüsselte Techniken, also HTTPS, auf deine Website zugreifen, ohne dass sie immer diese dummen Fensterchen kriegen, wo man irgendwie zehnmal klicken muss, bis man draufkommt, wie man drin ist, dann kriegst du von uns auch ein Cert. Und dann können die Leute irgendwie bei dir ohne große Fehlermeldungen ein bisschen HTTPS klicken. Und wenn sie sich dafür interessieren, dann können sie bei Netscape unten links auf diesen Schlüssel klicken. Dann sehen sie, dass das dein Cert ist, dass wir das unterschrieben haben. Und wir stehen dazu auch. Und da gibt es dann auch ein Klick, wo drin steht, was wir da unterschrieben haben. Nämlich mehr oder weniger, dass uns jemand etwas geschickt hat und dass wir das unterschrieben haben und dass wir es zurückgeschickt haben.
Ja, also wir bestätigen nämlich nicht, dass du Holgi bist, sondern nur, dass irgendwer sich Holgi nennt und der hat dieses Zertifikat. Also wenn du uns was schickst...
Und dass sich garantiert niemand anders mit denselben Daten auch Holgi genannt hat.
Genau, wenn du dich jetzt als Präsident Clinton uns was schickst, dann unterschreiben wir das auch. Und damit ist halt nur bestätigt, dass jemand sich Präsident Clinton nennt. Also es hat nichts irgendwie mit Realnamen zu tun.
Das ist klar. Also das ist absolut pseudonym.
Also es gibt halt keine zwei von diesen Pseudonymen. Und solange dieser Computer nicht gehackt wird, irgendwie kannst du dich auch mehr oder weniger darauf verlassen, dass das auch so stimmt.
Also wenn er gehackt wird, informiert er die Leute?
Wenn er gehackt wird, dann würden wir wahrscheinlich die Leute informieren. Sofern dann nicht jemand irgendwie so tut, als ob er unser Server wäre und behauptet irgendwie, dass wir nicht gehackt wurden. Also manchmal muss ich wahrscheinlich tot klatschen.
Meistens die Leute, die unsere Server hacken, auch so freundlich selber die anderen zu informieren, indem sie es auf unsere Homepage schreiben.
Wir konzeptionieren ein bisschen Musik.
Alle können euch hören. Ja, wir haben noch einen Hörer und zwar den Frank. Hallo Frank.
Hallo.
Dein Punkt totale Sicherheit bedeutet was?
Total Überwachung im Endeffekt, wenn man das auf den Punkt bringt. Denn wenn man sich das weiterdenkt, bedeutet das doch, wenn ich eine digitale Idee habe, dann ist das ja wie ein Ausweis, mit dem ich praktisch im Lanyard gehe und den vorher vorzeigen muss, dass ich ich bin. Und das bedeutet doch im Internet praktisch die total Überwachung, was ich da nun mache im Internet.
Wollen wir dann den Umkehrschluss auch fragen? Total unsicher ist es, totale Freiheit?
Also ich meine...
Wählen Sie jetzt.
Also ich bin lieber dafür, dass weniger Sicherheit im Internet ist und dafür keine so eine totale Überwachung ist. Weil diesen ganzen E-Commerce mach ich sowieso nicht mit, weil ich sag mir, weil gerade das Internet nicht so sicher ist, bestell ich also im Internet keine Produkte irgendwo.
Richtig heikel würde es ja auch werden, wenn du mit diesem Ausweis, den du hast, oder ohne diesen Ausweis gar nicht erst in den Laden reinkommen würdest, oder? Das wäre dann irgendwie das Ganze doch auf die Spitze getrieben.
Na würde dich die Idee reizen, dass es irgendwie zwei Internets gibt? So eins Blümchenwieser, eins Datenautobahn?
Naja, aber dann hast du ja irgendwann diese Zwei-Tlappen-Jesellschaft.
Ja, das coole Internets auf Blümchenwiese und das Kauf- und Fernsehinternets-Datenautobahn.
Ja, bloß wo man sich dann weiterspringen kann, dass man eventuell der Staat dann so weit geht, dass man diese Blümchenwiese, sagen wir mal, so aller Fernsehen abstumpfen lässt für die Otto-Normal-User, für die Dummen, sagen wir mal, und dieses andere, dieses Hochsicherheitsnetz, in Anführungsstrichen, wo die ihre Sachen dann drauf machen wieder.
Also es könnte sozusagen auch ein Konzept sein, dass man sagt, mit dem Vorwand der Einführung von digitalen Vertragsblablabla will man in Wirklichkeit nur die Blümchenwiese platt machen, und zwar mit den Beton, würd ich sagen.
Ja, so würd ich das sagen, denn ich sag mal so, mich interessieren zum Beispiel politische Seiten, und wenn ich jetzt jeder nachweisen kann, wer, was sich wo praktisch richtig per Ausweis, sag ich mal, wann angeklickt hat, klar geht jetzt auch schon, in Anführungsstrichen, aber der Aufwand ist noch relativ groß, sag ich mal. Dann würd ich also nicht mehr im Internet surfen wollen irgendwo. Dann würd ich die Sache lieber sein lassen.
Ja, und ich denk auch eine Menge Leute, also selbst von den Krawattenträgern, die ich so auf den Konferenzen erlebe, die digitalen Signaturen und den ganzen Unsinn wollen, wenn man dann darüber redet, sie wollen also auch, dass die nackten Weiber, die sie sich da angucken, wenn sie gerade nicht ihren Chef um sich herum haben, dass die dann also auch von ihnen digital signiert wahrgenommen werden und entsprechend das in ihren vertraglichen Beziehungen eingeht. Und dann in dem Moment wollen sie natürlich auch wieder nicht.
Ja, aber wo will man da den Abstrich machen? Ich meine, wenn man diesen Ding erstmal Tür und Tor öffnet, dann ist es ja zu rabbefahren, sagen wir mal.
Nein, nicht unbedingt. Also das Schöne an diesen ganzen Internetprotokollen ist, dass sie irgendwo auch flexibel sind. Also sprich, du kannst halt auf der gleichen Leitung IPSEC und anderes verhandeln. Also sprich, man könnte sich schon einloggen mit seinem Personal Cert in ein halt irgendwie Secure-Net, das halt innerhalb des gleichen Netzes, innerhalb der gleichen Infrastruktur, aber halt nur mit ver- äh, authentifizierten Teilen gelandet.
Ja, das Problem ist bloß, wenn alle gezwungen werden, sich zu authentifizieren, zum Beispiel mit der Begründung, um die Nile-of-Service-Attacken abzuwehren, dann bringt das alles nichts.
Du kommst in den Laden nicht mehr rein ohne Ausweis.
Ja, du kannst halt zum Beispiel als ECOM, äh, also als so eine Site, die halt schon versucht, damit Geld zu verdienen mit diesem Netz und dafür Sicherheit brauchst, kannst du halt sagen, ab diesem Router so 500 Kilometer vor mir, kommen halt nur noch Leute rein, die über IPSEC irgendwie sich authentifiziert haben, und zwar von Punkt zu Punkt, vom Server bis wirklich zu dem Rechner, der Teil abgemacht hat. Naja, aber dann sind wir ja doch sozusagen bei der NSA-Theorie, kommen wir noch etwas gründlicher.
Ja, eben, ich sehe da die Gefahr, also praktisch, dass der Staat da noch besser eine Möglichkeit hat, die einzelnen Bürger praktisch noch zentraler zu überwachen.
Ja, und zwar noch sehr viel besser.
Er hat ja gesagt, ich bin großzügig und lasse beim Signaturgesetz Pseudonyme zu. Aber wenn ich wissen will, wer das ist, dann rufe ich bei der Zertifizierungsstelle an und die sollen mir den Namen geben. Also irgendwie war das doch nicht so ernst gemeint mit den Pseudonymen.
Naja, die Pseudonyme haben schon den Vorteil, dass du zum Beispiel nicht gegenüber jedermann deinen Klarnamen sagen musst, aber der Staat als irgendwie die Zentrale hat immer wieder Künstlernamen im Personalausweis. Also das ist irgendwie die Kitas hier ja auf dem Umsteg.
Also der Staat kommt quasi jederzeit daran.
Natürlich, der hat immer mich im Umsteg. Frank, alles klar.
Ich denke, wir nehmen das mal ein.
Ja klar, Entschuldigung, bitte.
Nein, wir wollen weniger Sicherheit, fand ich eine gute Aussage.
Ja, mit Jürgen, Jürgen willst du auch weniger Sicherheit.
Ja, ich wollte mich nur melden, ja. Ich würde sagen, hier ist Mathe.
Schönen Gruß an den Aufnahmeleit.
Oh man, ich kann da hier auch noch mal kurz. Ich hab ja auch noch alle Beiträge. Ja, nach dem Gruß und weg dafür. Also, ich hab jetzt Spaß im Internet, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe. Das ist jetzt so das Thema. Nein, ich meine, die Frage ist doch tatsächlich die. Wir sind uns aber einig, wenn wir irgendwie da Sicherheit und Verbindlichkeit wollen. Dann gibt es da klare Wege für, da können wir die Techniken benennen. Die bringen aber zwangsläufig auch mehr Überwachung. Weil die nämlich letztendlich, und das ist auch der, was ich sozusagen, nehmen wir mal an, E-Commerce ist, Duby hat mir netterweise hier so eine Definition hingeschrieben, die will ich jetzt mal treuhänderisch glauben, elektronische Vertragsanwarnung und Vertragsabschluss. Nehmen wir mal an, das ist so. Jetzt ist aber die Sache die. Nehmen wir mal an, ich geh in so einen Laden rein und sag irgendwie eine Pizza. Dann ist es dem Händler selbstverständlich wichtig, dass ich jetzt nicht einfach die Pizza nehme und rausrenne. Der will auch nicht, dass ich, bevor er mir die Pizza in die Hand gedrückt hab, rausrenne. Der will mein Geld zählen. Dem ist es schon irgendwie, das ist ihm wichtig.
Klar.
Wenn er allerdings seine Kohle gekriegt hat und ich die Pizza hab, dann ist dem ziemlich egal, wer ich bin. Das ist dem Wurst. Das ist nicht wichtig. Zwischen der Authentifizierung, sprich, dass man sagt, wir sind jetzt gerade in einem Geschäft, und da geht es darum, dass wir uns anständig verhalten, der Identifizierung im Sinne von, ich weiß wer du bist und kann dich dann hinterher an den Karren pinkeln, oder was auch immer, ist ja auch noch ein Unterschied. Was jetzt eben in der Diskussion rauskam, und das glaube ich stimmt schon, ist, dass wenn wir diese Signierungsnummer machen, dann landen wir letztendlich in einem Netz, wo jeder alles nachvollziehen kann, wo die einzelnen Tätigkeiten das Einzelne nachvollziehen. Aber dann traust du dem Internet als gewachsene Struktur und auch ein bisschen anarchistisch im Dingster, insofern nicht, also traust du ihm einfach nicht, dass es das überlebt, dass es beides sein kann? Nee, ich glaube, du hast doch selber gesagt, dass sie es in die Router einbauen wollen. Und wenn das auf Router-Ebene anfängt, und wir alle irgendwie unsere statische IP-Nummer haben, und die dann möglicherweise noch mit induktiv ausläsbaren Chip unter der Haut haben, ich meine, schonmal, was ist denn da noch von der Anarchie des Netzes übrig?
Na ja, das gucken wir nach den Nachrichten, was wir wirklich sehen.
Vorhaben Bundeskanzler Schröder will EDV-Experten aus dem Ausland nach Deutschland holen. Bei der Eröffnung der Computermesse Cebit am Abend in Hannover sagte Schröder, man werde den Fachkräften eine Aufenthaltserlaubnis nach dem Vorbild der US-Green Card geben. Gleichzeitig forderte der Kanzler die Wirtschaft auf, arbeitslose deutsche Ingenieure für die Computerbranche umzuschulen. Demonstrationen rund 2000 Menschen haben am Abend in Brandenburg-Haffel gegen die geplanten Kürzungen bei den Kitas protestiert. Vertreter der Demonstranten übergaben Listen mit gesammelten Unterschriften. Zu den Protesten hatte die Gewerkschaft ÖTV aufgerufen. Sie sieht durch die Einsparung den gesetzlichen Betreuungsanspruch in Kindertagesstätten und Arbeitsplätze bedroht. Beschluss, die Aufsichtsräte der Energiekonzerne RWE und VEW haben heute einem Zusammenschluss zugestimmt. Der dann größte deutsche Energieversorger soll einen Umsatz von rund 43 Milliarden Euro erwirtschaften. Von der Fusion verspricht man sich Einsparung von jährlich über 700 Millionen Euro. 3.200 Stellen sollen wegfallen. Fortschritt, die Einrichtung von sogenannten Fixerstuben wird in Deutschland legalisiert. Der Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundesrat und Bundestag einigte sich am Abend auf einen leicht geänderten Gesetzentwurf. Heute soll das Gesetz den Bundestag passieren. In einem Testländerspiel besiegte die niederländische Fußballauswahl am Abend in Deutschland das deutsche, nee, in Amsterdam das deutsche Team mit 2 zu 1.
Wetter.
Heute Nacht ging bewölkt 0 bis minus 4 Grad am Tag, dann bewölkt und erregnerisch Scheißwetter um 7 Grad. Verkehr. Zurzeit keine aktuellen Meldungen.
Das heißt, der Schwertransport hat Brandenburg sozusagen verlassen.
Ja, hoffe ich doch, dass der mal gut nach Hause kommt.
Um 00.33 Uhr in Kürz und Kürt.
Heute Nacht von 1 bis 4 Uhr im Night Flight auf Ritz. Musik von Non-Place Urban Field, Drone, Flanger, mit einem Wort von Bernd Friedmann aus Köln. Bernd Friedmann im Interview, mit jeder Menge unveröffentlichtem Material und seinem neuen Album Bernd Friedmann & The New Dub Players. Heute Nacht von ein bis vier Uhr im Night Flight auf Ritz.
Also im Prinzip hatten wir jetzt irgendwie dran, dass das mit den digitalen Signaturen schon irgendwie ganz praktisch wäre, weil man damit natürlich eine Menge Lauferei ersparen kann und vielleicht auch ein bisschen ein paar Bäume sparschont und dass man damit nette Sachen machen kann. Bloß leider irgendwie die Rechner, auf denen man das machen könnte, das finde ich so zu Hause, weil von da aus will man das ja machen, nicht so in der Zustand sind, dass man das darauf wirklich tun möchte, weil wegen unsicher, wegen Backallkissen oder was auch immer.
Ich dachte, wir hatten uns darauf geeinigt, dass der Sicherheit total Überwachung ist und über unsichere Rechner zu Hause hatten wir gar nicht gesprochen.
Nee, das hatten wir ja vorhin schon dran und dann irgendwie.
Das ist aber wirklich eine gute Stunde hier. Ja, aber wir hatten es auf jeden Fall. Ich wollte dir jetzt Pluto unterstützend unter den Stuhl greifen.
Ich will nicht wieder runterfallen. Ich fühle mich sicher auf. In diesem Fall zertifiziert und sicher aufgehoben. Ja, das andere Extrem ist dann irgendwie so, dass die Freiheit im Internet und was wir davon wollen und ob es da eine Zusammenführung gibt.
Einen Feldweg zwischen Datenautobahn und Blümchenwiese. Also gibt es einen?
Na, ich muss erst mal sagen, wenn jetzt die ganzen Händler mit ihren Händlerkarren über die Blümchenwiese drüber fahren wollen, können sie das ja zur Not machen, aber meiner Meinung nach, wenn sie dann im Schlamm stecken bleiben, ist das halt ihr Problem. Lassen sie nicht über eine Wiese fahren.
Ja, aber ist das...
Das macht mal den Händlern klar. Also das macht mal den Händlern klar und vor allen Dingen den Lobbyisten der Händler.
Frag mal, der Korrerschieb schon durch ganz andere Sachen durchgefahren und hat immer noch ihren Kram verkauft und nicht dadurch gemacht.
Das sind ja vor allen Dingen letztlich auch diese Händler, die dem Gesetzgeber nötigen, Gesetze zu erlassen, die es den Händlern ermöglichen, nicht mehr im Schlamm stecken bleiben zu müssen.
Ich dachte, wir sind für die Verschwörungstheorien zuständig.
Entschuldigung, also das... Nein, aber das ist doch... Ich meine, ich wollte nicht... Ich habe... Bitte mich aufs Entschuldigung.
Also die Händler haben den Gesetzgeber gezwungen, dieses Gesetz zu machen.
Nein, aber es ist doch... Ich meine... Das hat doch auch nichts mit Verschwörungstheorie zu tun. Es ist doch ganz einfach so, dass wenn du einem Konzern, der Entschuldige an die E-Commerce machen willst, sagst, klar kannst du machen, aber wenn du auf die Fresse fällst, ist es dein Problem, dann sagt der Konzern, okay, dann stellen wir eben keine tausend Leute ein. Und über dieses Arbeitslosenproblem ist der Gesetzgeber auch immer korrumpierbar.
Nein, ich meine Geschäftsmodelle kalkulieren ja immer fließig einatmend. Ich meine, wenn du irgendwie einen Laden aufmachst, dann weißt du auch, Ladendiebstahl kannst du nicht ganz verhindern, musst du ein bisschen Schwund einrechnen und gut ist so. Und so ungefähr sind ja auch die jetzigen Geschäftsmodelle da. Die Frage ist eben im Bezug auf darauf ja auch geht, diese digitale Signatur sozusagen, wenn man jetzt von der Händlertheorie ausgeht, nicht an den Bedürfnissen da total vorbei. Weil wie gesagt, ich glaube dem Händler ist es wichtig, dass er seine Asche sieht, seine Kohle, sein Geld, aber nicht unbedingt, dass er weiß, wer das ist. Das ist zwar irgendwie nett, wenn er ihn verkagen kann, aber er will ihn ja gar nicht verkagen, sondern er will sein Geld haben.
Und der ist ja auch zufrieden, wenn er eine Kreditkartennummer hat.
Zum Beispiel oder von mir aus...
Nee, das mit den Kreditkartennummern, das wollen die Händler nicht, weil das kostet irgendwie 312% und so. Von mir aus reden wir auch irgendwann noch mal über Elektrogeld, Cybercash, E-cash und den ganzen anderen Katzen weg. Aber so, jetzt waren wir ganz kurz bei der Händlertheorie und die Staatstheorie. Klar ist es cool, wenn wir unsere Steuererklärung abgeben können und partiell. Also es gibt sicherlich Anwendungen, wo wir Gottverdammt die Identifizierung brauchen, auch wenn wir sie nicht mögen. Die Frage ist, muss man dazu das Netz entkrempeln oder reicht es, wenn diejenigen, die das unbedingt wollen, sich so eine blöde Chipkarte hinstellen und dann sollen sie halt im Zweifelszeit bis an ihr Lebensende bluten, wenn jemand es doch schafft, das Ding zu überwinden.
Oder ist das Ordnungsamt gegebenenfalls so umstrukturierbar, dass man nur noch eine Stunde da sitzen muss, wenn man irgendwie...
Ja, ich meine, die können ja auch mal Computer mitnehmen.
Lieber nicht.
Lieber nicht, meinst du. Ja oder ist es das Netz einfach groß genug, flexibel genug und anpassbar genug, dass beides geht?
Also, Andy hatte vor den Nachrichten, wie uns vielleicht diese ganze Signaturkram ungefragt reingedrückt wird, du hast gesagt, irgendwie beim Pizzamann möchtest du nicht deinen Ausweis vorzeigen müssen. Ist verständlich.
Nee, der Pizzamann interessiert sich auch gar nicht für meinen Ausweis. Der will Geld und zufriedene Kunden und ich will Happy Happy.
Bloß fast alle Ansätze, die gepusht werden für elektronisches Bezahlen, da ist irgendwie auf jeder Geldnote dein Ausweis und deine Schuhgröße aufgedruckt, weil die alle mit irgendwelchen Signaturverfahren arbeiten und im Prinzip Geldkarte und so, da wird ja im Prinzip dir zwangsweise aufgedruckt, dass du bei jedem Händler deinen Namen hinterlässt und so gesehen, kriegt man das schon ganz klar.
Aber bei der Geldkarte schon. Außer Aufdruck, der Datenschützer sind die White Cards eingeführt worden. Ja.
Aber die kannst du nirgendwo aufladen.
White Card bedeutet, du hast eine Geldkarte, die nicht auf Konton zu uns.
Also es gibt Personen, die oben gebohlen sind, Geldkarten. Theoretisch sollte. Praktisch wird aber auch da jeder einzelne Einkauf über 6 Jahre gespeichert. Ein Bewegungs- und Konsumprofil ist jederzeit erstellbar.
Du hast dann abgeglichen mit dem Handy, was du eh in der Tasche hast.
Sondern wir sind da jetzt auch schon irgendwie 20 vor 1. Also das grobe Bild so, okay, die Verlockung ist groß, gleichzeitig eben noch Daten für Kundenprofile und für staatliche Überwachung und für allen Unsinn zu gewinnen. Und das ist glaube ich der Kampf, der läuft, kann man sagen, oder? Also ich meine, in der Wirtschaft zumindest höre ich nicht viel von der digitalen Signatur. Wenn ich da auf irgendwelchen Krawattenträgernkonferenzen mich umhöre, die wollen verbindliche Zahlverfahren haben, die wollen ihr Geld haben, die wollen möglicherweise sogar anonyme Zahlverfahren, wenn sie dadurch mehr Kunden haben, hauptsache sie kriegen ihr Geld. So und sie haben ja auch schon gemerkt, dass so diese Assoziation Überwachungstechnologie und ein sicheres Geschäft nicht unbedingt einen zustrebenden Kundenauflauf irgendwie zuträglich ist. Ja, also die Imageverluste durch irgendwelchen Verrat von Geheimnissen, also sprich Kundendaten an andere. An dieser Stelle möchte ich übrigens ganz öffentlich irgendwie die GMD erwähnen, die mir irgendwie seit einem Jahr, seitdem sie meine Adresse verkauft haben, irgendwie einmal pro Woche irgendwie ein bisschen öfter Geld beschert. Also das macht irgendwie keinen Spaß.
Die GMD, was?
Also das konnten wir jetzt alle nicht verstehen.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade nur ein deutsches Forschungsinstitut als Beispiel dafür genannt, wie man, wenn man sich im Internet seine Adresse hinterlässt, um zum Beispiel etwas downzuloten, was eigentlich kostenlos ist, plötzlich irgendwie hinterher irgendwie einen Coop Web Magazin zweimal pro Woche irgendwie anzeigen und sonstiges im Briefkasten hat. Und das ist noch das Harmloseste, was passieren kann. Spam, in dem Fall Real Life, die man selber wegschmeißen muss, nicht mit Ctrl-D.
Das ist mir auch passiert.
Nach drei Wochen, nachdem ich in meine neue Wohnung gezogen bin, hatte ich Post von, äh, was war das, ZDNet oder so?
Gibt's, ja.
Also, keine Ahnung, die wollten mir auch noch solche Zeitschriften nachdrücken. Ich weiß auch bis heute nicht, wo die Herztee haben.
Ja, das ist nicht schön. Das ist nicht das, was wir wollen. Das wollen auch die Anbieter nicht. Also, wo ist da der Weg dazwischen der? Tja, ich denke, wenn ich jetzt noch mal ganz kurz über die Blümchenwiese reden darf, da, wie gesagt, kommen mir die Juristen sowieso ein bisschen wie Fremdkörper vor, weil auf der Blümchenwiese, da vertraut man sich eigentlich gegenseitig und Blümchenwiesen sind nicht auf Misstrauen gebaut. Aber auf Mist.
Je mehr Mist, desto blüder.
Misstrauen ist nicht Mist. Also, ich glaube, Mist kann man eben besser kompostieren als Misstrauen. Also, wenn ich irgendwie Misstrauen eine Runde sacken lasse, dann kommen die Juristen und Schäfeln Geld. Und wenn ich Mist eine Runde sacken lasse, dann wachsen mir die Blüten drauf. Also, insofern ist mir der Mist irgendwie lieber.
Jetzt ist Duby gefragt, der Jurist.
Aber ich meine, die Frage ist, wie schaffen wir es in demselben Netz, die Blümchenwiese mit unseren Anforderungen, die einfach mit digitalen Sinkengladkuren und Authentifikationen und Identifikationen und diesem ganzen Kumis nichts zu tun haben, so wie schaffen wir es die parallel zu einem, ja, okay, wenn ich ein Auto kaufe, dann will der Händler sein Geld und will auch wissen, wer ich bin und so weiter.
Na, er will sicher sein können, dass er sein Geld bekommt.
Ja, und Herr Gott, okay, ja, natürlich muss das Finanzamt wissen, wenn ich eine Steuererklärung abgebe, dass ich das bin und wenn ich mich irgendwie melde oder was weiß ich was tue mit dem Staat, so die ihn dann nicht einfach auflösen, müssen wir uns wohl da an einigen Stellen in Kommunikationsprozesse begeben.
Also was erstmal sehr interessant ist, die Leute, die mit Geld arbeiten und handeln, die brauchen den Staat nicht, die regeln das unter sich. Die Banken machen schon ewig elektronischen Datenverkehr und zwar ohne Signaturgesetz. Und die Händler haben irgendwie in den letzten 500 Jahren ganz schön raffinierte Techniken entwickelt, wie sie sicherstellen, dass der eine seine Sachen und der andere sein Geld kriegt, obwohl der eine in Hongkong ist und der andere in London und irgendwie einen Brief mit Postschiff sechs Monate braucht.
Also spiel es jetzt auf die Hansa an. Also sprich, sie haben halt Privatarmee gegründet, um dafür zu sorgen, dass die Kunden...
Nein, nein, nein.
Da gibt es auch andere Konzepte.
Bezahlsysteme und sowas, die es irgendwie seit Ewigkeiten schon gibt. Und die Banken zum Beispiel sorgen ja selber für ihre Authentifizierung und solche Sachen. Also große Unternehmen wissen eigentlich in der Regel, wie sie das selber regern, ohne den Staat. Da hilft es denen in der Regel auch nicht, wenn sie wissen, wer was gekauft hat, wenn er nicht bezahlen kann, sondern die wollen sichergestellt haben, dass du das Geld hast für das, was du kaufst und nicht, dass du du bist. Weil irgendwie, wenn ich dir ein Dreißig... 30 Tonnen Sand vor die Tür kippen, dann bringt es mir nicht, wenn ich dich nachher auf das Geld verklagen kann, sondern ich will dir das nur vor die Tür kippen, wenn ich weiß, dass ich das Geld kriege, wenn du es eh nicht bezahlen kannst. Na, Sand ist vielleicht nicht so das gute Beispiel. Aber wenn ich dir ein Haus verkaufe und du ziehst ein, dann bringt es mir nicht, wenn ich dich verklagen kann, sondern ich will dich gar nicht erst einziehen lassen, wenn du nicht das Geld für die Bude hast.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte ein anonymes Geld und würde dieses Geld zertifizieren.
Da kann man irgendwie drüber reden. Das ist in der Tat ein Konzept. Damit haben wir aber noch nicht das Problem mit der Steuererklärung gelöst. Es sei denn natürlich, ich gebe überhaupt keine Steuererklärung mehr ab, sondern schicke dem blöden Finanzamt die 3, 50 Mark für die Umsätze, die ich gemacht habe. Und dann sollen sie mich doch in Rundlass und eigentlich geht es sie auch nicht an, mit wem ich welche Umsätze gemacht habe. Das Problem ist dann bloß, dass nicht einmal pro Woche der Mistwagen kommt und deine Blümchenwiese düngt, damit du weiterhin deine Blümchen pflücken kannst. Ach komm, also um die Pflege der Blümchenwiese, da kann man gerne mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Aber ich meine, das hat mehr was mit Geschenkkultur zu tun und dem auch vertrauensvollen Umgang mit seinen Mitmenschen und dem freien Hereinstellen von Informationen, in dem glaube das andere das auch tun und dann profiliert man da letztendlich auch von. Also da hast du dich eigentlich nicht zu die Sorgen, zu die Blümchenwiese, die wächst und gedeiht. Aber Open Source als Geschäftsmodell klappt halt mit Informationen, die du beliebig oft replizieren kannst. Sobald du Sachen hast, wie z.B. Mist, den du brauchst, um die Blümchen an Wachsen zu halten, hast du etwas, was du nicht kopieren kannst. Das heißt, immaterielle Güter sind fast anderes als immaterielle Güter.
Also, dass die Blümchenwiese wächst und gedeiht, glaube ich gar nicht mal. Sowas wie, ja, who is down macht nichts. Also für die Blümchenwiese kann man halt irgendwie mal einen Tag lang nicht auf einen Webkatalog zugreifen. Wenn die Nameserver, die Rootnameserver alle down sind, dann ist das was anderes. Und wenn man irgendwie jetzt mit Selbstheilungskräften kommt, wir haben das beim Usenet, die Älteren unter den Hörern werden sich erinnern, das war mal eine formose Sache, das ist völlig unbrauchbar inzwischen. Das ist ein Haufen Müll, Werbung, Pornografie, man kann es nicht mehr benutzen. Oder nur noch mit irgendwie richtig hohem Aufwand, mit Killfiles und Filtern und Grubblends und haste nicht.
Also das Usenet ist hinüber.
Da hat jemand die Blümchenwiese so viel Mist drauf gekippt, dass man es nicht mehr benutzen kann.
Also sprich, es ist da bei Anarchie. Es ist schon ausgenutzt und jetzt hat man irgendwie das große Chaos, was keiner mehr haben will, auch wenn alle Leute auf Anarchie eigentlich Bock haben. Aber die Frage ist ja, was tun wir dagegen? Und die Blümchenwiese ist ja im Moment erstmal nur das freie Hereinstellen von Informationen und so weiter und so fort. Und ich meine im Usenet, okay, da haben wir das Problem, dass wir da echt Fremdkörper drin haben, echt Leute, die es nicht begriffen haben, die glauben, Werbespläne irgendwie macht sie reich oder was auch immer. Ja, man zwingt sie zu Klarnamen, wie in vielen Newsgroups, und damit hast du halt schon wieder so den Anfang, der Versuch, irgendwie eine Authentifizierung der Leute irgendwie zu machen, der da auch irgendwie so einfach als Selbstteilungskraft oder als irgendwie Notwehr irgendwo gemacht wurde, wo Leute halt ohne Klarnamen in vielen Newsgroups nicht mehr posten dürfen, weil sonst genau dieses Problem besteht, dass halt diese Blümchenwiese einfach missbraucht wird. Und sprich, es gibt da Blümchen, alle finden die Blümchen toll und alle gehen dahin und pflücken sie und gehen wieder weg.
Naja, und was ist, wenn das jetzt mit den Servern, wo freie Informationen aufgestellt werden...
Aber das ist zum Beispiel, das kannst du nicht übertragen. Das ist ein Beispiel aus materiellen Raum.
Also wenn einfach jetzt zu viele Leute irgendwie mal ihre DOS-Tools ausprobieren...
Du meinst, wenn jetzt die 14-Jährigen sich mal organisieren, der Informatiklehrer hat vielleicht auch gerade schlechte Laune und dann fahren sie mal richtig mit der Schulklasse mal den Kram runter. Ja, dann haben einige die Brille auf. Dann kommen aber sicherlich als allererstes mal Sicherungsmaßnahmen dagegen, dass sich irgendwelche Computer als Angriffswerkzeug missbrauchen lassen. Weil dazu braucht man keine Authentifizierung und keine Identifizierung, keine digitalen Signaturen und schon gar keinen Gesetzgeber, sondern man braucht Leute, die wissen, was in ihren Computern passiert und die eventuell sogar dafür bezahlt werden, wenn sie schon dafür bezahlt sind, einen Computer zu betreiben, der auch tatsächlich dem sicher zu betreiben und sich umzuhorchen, was da so an Informationen kommt, ob es da Tools gibt und ob man das abwehren kann. Also Enforcement, also über staatlich oder sonst wie verordnete Sicherheit, ist dann natürlich eh noch ein interessantes Aspekt. Im Sinne von, wenn der Staat Internet als grundlegende Infrastruktur begreift, dann wird er versuchen, es zu schützen. Sprich, er wird als Amelie... Das ist ja in Amerika, da heißt das Ganze ja Nationales Komitee zur Schutz der Infrastruktur. Und die Datenautobahnen, wie sie dort heißt, Information Highway ist ja da mehr oder weniger erklärte Regierungsgedönensaufgabe.
Wobei interessanterweise ja nicht der Regierung gehört.
Nee, das nicht, aber die Autobahnen gehören ja in Amerika auch nicht durch, in der Region nimmst du auch private Betreiber und lassen trotzdem ihre Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen, wenn die Autobahnen nicht werden.
Das ist ja der Gedanke der Schicksalsgemeinschaft.
Ja, wird echt zäh, wenn man in die Richtung denkt. Ja, es gibt halt so ein paar Sachen, die man eigentlich nicht will, wo man aber irgendwie schwierig drum rumkommt, auf die alte Frage zurückkommt, irgendwie verhungern oder erschießen sich die Leute nach, die eigentlich hier als Erstes. Naja, es könnte ja auch sein, dass sie sich irgendwie lieb haben und tolle Dinge tun.
Oder müssen wir vielleicht, wenn wir das Usen dann einfach mal exemplarisch nehmen, reicht es vielleicht auch, wenn wir einfach warten, und zwar so lange, bis dieses exponentielle Wachstum der Userzahl aufgehört hat und die Leute angefangen haben, ein bisschen Verantwortung zu entwickeln?
Ich glaube nicht, nicht genau deswegen nicht.
Vielleicht liegt es einfach nur daran, die holen sich eine AOL-CD, schmeißen die rein und scheißen erstmal das Usenet zu.
Das Problem sind Gruppen, die eine gewisse Größe überschritten haben, sind die einzelnen Individuen nicht mehr in der Lage, sich für die Gesamtgruppe verantwortlich zu führen. Wenn du 500 Leute hast, die eine Szene ausmachen, oder sagen wir mal 10.000 Leute, die das Usenet benutzen, wo man sich mehr oder weniger noch irgendwo kennt, dann fühlst du dich als Einzelindividuum für diesen Komplex, in dem du verhaftet bist, irgendwo verantwortlich. Sprich, du schmeißt halt keinen Müll auf die Straße. Wenn du ein Einzelindividuum in einem irgendwie 100 Millionen oder 60 Millionen Klicker sollst du da draußen geben, ein Staat bist, dann verlierst du dieses Verantwortungsgefühl für die soziale Gruppe, in der du dich befindest.
Gibt es da noch eine Lösung in die Richtung?
Ja, dann vielleicht noch die Zentralisierung, die Verkleinerung, kleinere Kulturzirkel. Und ich meine, das passiert ja auch. Also ich denke, eine Folge davon, dass das Usenet an einigen Stellen nicht mehr zu gebrauchen ist, dass die Anzahl der E-Mail-Verteiler, sprich kleinerer Kommunikationsräume, wo Leute sich fachspezifisch austauschen und wo in der Regel auch nur die Leute die Leute selbst auf die Mailing-Liste draufschreiben dürfen, die da drin sind. Sprich, man kackt nicht in seine eigene Wohnung. Man reduziert die Gruppe einfach wieder? Ja, beziehungsweise die Kommunikationsräume werden halt wiederum zu überschauen. Im Prinzip sind dann so Mailing-Listen so das, was irgendwie Gibson drin hatte, irgendwie mit der World City im Sinne von das Kill-Fall nach außen gekehrt, im Sinne von man killt halt nicht mehr alle Leute im Usenet, die man nicht mag, sondern man lässt halt nur noch die Leute rein, die man mag und dafür hat man eine Whitelist und das sind halt die Subscriber dieser Mailing-Liste. Na, na, also ob das jetzt gleich killen und Whitelisting ist, weiß ich nicht. Also ich geh auch in Mailing-Listen rein, wo ich irgendwie weiß, da sind bestimmt Leute drin, die ich nicht leiden kann, mit denen ich mich aber vielleicht streiten will, so mit denen will ich mich einfach lustig streiten und ich will aber nicht die Werbespammer drin haben, die mir nebenbei irgendwie auf Arabisch irgendwie Produkte anbieten, die ich nicht mal identifizieren kann, so das will ich einfach nicht, das kostet mich nur blöde Zeit.
Das Usenet-Effekt ist irgendwie eigentlich das, was du vor zehn Jahren gepredigt hast, dein Spruch.
Ich gepredigt?
Computer sind Kommunikationsverstärker, das fühlst du doch immer auf die Lippen.
Strukturverstärker.
Das Problem ist, dass sie für Leute, die einen mit einem kommunizieren wollen und man will das selber nicht, auch Verstärker sind. Und aus Usenet, da kannst du als eine Person irgendwie hunderttausend Leuten auf die Nerven gehen und eine Person wird es immer geben, deshalb wird sich das glaube ich auch nicht beruhigen.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es irgendwie ein Arschloch gibt, ist irgendwie bei hunderttausend Leuten definitiv höher als bei hundert. Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, ist der Arschlochquotient irgendwann zu hoch? Ich meine, da gibt es ja auch wieder Methoden dagegen. Das nennt man dann Immunität des Teilnehmers vor irgendwie Mediengeschehen. Herr, lasst Medienkompetenz auf uns herab zu regeln, irgendwie bringt es in die Schulen, irgendwie schickt den Chili mal in die Internetschulung, damit er nicht irgendwie sagt, ich will jetzt das Internet verbieten, damit es sicher wird, sondern damit er versteht, was im Bildungsministerium zu passieren hat.
Ist das Lösung für unseren Scheldweg haben wir bei mir noch nicht, ne?
Naja, also ich meine, Dezentralisierung, also ist das mit den großen Räumen, die großen Räume werden dann unübersichtlich und dann kommen die mit den Bulldozern und meinen, sie können da jetzt auch mal rüberfahren und dann fangen welche Leute an. Ja, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen wild fest, aber... Ja, du hast halt einfach tierisch viele Leute, wenn du 10 Leute auf einer Blümchenwiese hast, dann werden sie ihren Müll mitnehmen. Wenn du tausend Leute auf einer Blümchenwiese hast, sie irgendwie Parade... Wenn die alle wohl erzogen sind, dann werden sie ihren Müll nehmen. Weil sie davon ausgehen, dass in tausend Leuten ist bestimmt auch einer, der sein Müll ein bisschen wegschmeißt und wenn da noch einer ist, der das macht, ach, dann mach ich das auch. Dann ist keiner mehr zuordnend. Ja, aber Moment, Moment. Meinst du nicht, dass wenn die irgendwie ein bisschen Hirn da hätten, wo es üblicherweise hingehört, dass sie es dann nicht tun würden?
Sie werden es auf jeden Fall tun.
Das machen sogar wir selber irgendwie. Wenn wir auf Karneval oder Love Parades sind, dann lassen wir doch auch mal unseren Becher fallen.
Weil ja eh alles versaut ist.
Da werden ja auch Leute dafür bezahlt.
Auf dem Camp hab ich meinen Müll weggeschmissen, weil ich auch erstmal durch die Einlasskontrolle musste.
Ja gut, aber auch jeden haben da mit jedem ein Beutel in die Hand gedrückt.
Klar, aber es ist eine riesen Gruppe zwar, aber da hast du dann auch wieder das, dass du sagst, ich hab eine Whitelist und hier kommt nur der durch, der das Bändchen hat.
Ja, aber wenn du zum Beispiel mal das untere Hacksender nach dem diesjährigen Kongress angeguckt hast, wo es echt voll war und botiert war... Lass uns doch nicht da drüber reden. Das war nicht mehr Verantwortung für die Gemeinschaft und für das Wohl der Gemeinschaft. Da lag der Müll echt so hoch. Um 9 Uhr morgens drin und... Hey, ist schon okay. Ich muss erst den Hausverfug überrechtfertigen. Also ihr merkt schon, wir werden uns auch nicht einig bei diesem Thema. Ja, wir wollen die Blümchenwiese, ja, wir wollen auch ein bisschen Verbindlichkeit. Nein, wir wollen keinen Überwachungsstaat und... Na, wir wollen die technische Entwicklung in diese Richtung. Könnt ihr euch auch jederzeit auf https://www.cccde informieren. Oder vielleicht präsentieren wir euch auch schon nächsten Monat hier auf dem letzten Mittwochmonat sinnvolle Konzepte, um diese Ziele zu erreichen.
März, nächsten Monat März.
Nächster Monat, ja, das ist dann von mir aus März.
Am letzten Mittwoch im März.
Wenn irgendwas an eurer Technik nicht klappt, dann könnt ihr auch mal darüber nachdenken, ob das nicht vielleicht an euch liegt, anstatt jemand anderem.
Na, ich weiß nicht, aber ich finde das eben so mit Opt-in. Opt-in ist halt irgendwie geil, wenn man die Wahl hat, zwischen irgendwie Blümchenwiese und Autobahn, und nicht dazu gezwungen wird, entweder mit den Freaks irgendwie Blümchen zu schnuppern, oder mit den Spinnern irgendwie Highspeed, irgendwie E-Commerce zu machen. Dann ist das irgendwo nett.
Wie war das Fachwort? Sozialromantiker? Oder wie nannte man sowas?
Ja, also, keine Ahnung. Also ich meine, steigern wir mal die Anzahl der Handlungsoptionen, indem wir noch mehr Transparenz in den Farben hineinbringen. Aber, lassen wir uns mal nicht von den Bürgern überrollen, ne?
Sehr schön, sehr schönes Schlusswort. Bisschen sozialromantische Musik noch.
Gute Nacht Brandenburg, gute Nacht Berlin.
Das war's, Chaosradio 47. Bis nächstes Mal am letzten Mittwoch im März.